you'll find that councelor hmer has been
replaced by councelor orok no not yet
not yet not officially
okay
okay right then oh it's going to be one
of those days today I can really
see so just for clarification councilor
har is still a member of this committee
and hasn't been replaced but he likely
to be replaced by councilor orok who's
here attending as an observer and is ex
officio because you're the chairperson
right so you're there with two
reasons right good we will get some
clarity we will move on I can to say
it's going to be one of those days today
so um right then any anything else
before we go on to disclosure of
Interest no disclosive interest please
can W Huggins
yeah I'm declaring sorry I'm declaring
an interest in item number seven the
cabinet agenda item number five in that
my husband is the managing director of a
fuel uh Distribution Company I am not a
shareholder of the company and nor do I
have any role within the company the
company does not distribute hvo fuels
and neither do we have any con cont
neither does the the company have any
contracts with biffer or their
subsidiaries I am not predetermined
remain impartial and we'll take part in
the debate thank you thank you that's
noted Council W hoggins any other
disclosures I did forget to welcome
councelor hener sarapin so welcome canel
hener
serin thank you chair I'm glad your puns
are as bad as mine so I look forward to
those keeping us nice and bright as well
so when it's warmer they will arrive
thank
you right item number three minutes of
previous meetings uh the minutes of
meetings held on the 17th of November
and the 1st of
December have members any points they
want to raise or uh things of inaccuracy
emissions Etc or
we do you want to make a comment on them
C with
yeah I think you might have to
use because
when you did it before it wasn't working
properly it's really item um 400 on the
work plan and the timings of this
meeting is the intention then that we
should all budget time till 2 o' for
future agendas or will we be advised I
will be on when the agenda arrives
whether we
should
you must be py councelor Johnson I will
be raising something on the Chairman's
brief about the next
meeting about that um we intend usually
to keep the meetings up to up to three
hours um preferably less if if hopefully
but there will be occasions where we
will have such a PR agenda and things
that can't be moved that they'll like to
go on and next next month's meeting is
is going to be one of those so um I'll
talk about that in chers
brief can off
please yeah um firstly um uh the London
and quadrant Housing Association I want
to apologize for taking so much time at
that meeting but just to tell you that
some really good has come out of this
and that um in two weeks time I have a
meeting with all the residents in fact
80% of the residents have responded
and they are coming to the meeting with
London and quadrant and with the
management company and I have already
already received 12 questions of from
people that can't turn up at the meeting
so it's been a good thing um and it's
been good communication with Len q and
myself yeah that's very positiv I know
what um I think the questions lasted
about 50 55 minutes last time which is
unprecedented I I've never used
presidented before um so uh it's uh we
have't learned lessons on that we
probably
did I should have probably ensured the
answers to the questions were more
concise that was the learning point um
but I couldn't curb the enthusiasm of
the people answering the questions which
is unusual from from some external
speakers who sometimes are quite
reluctant to give out information and
and I I didn't want to uh stop the
person in full flow the person was giv
that some good information and obviously
it's had beneficial effects for Council
ral's resident so right I any other
comments or you happy that I sign those
minutes at a a later date yes aged thank
you um I'm just saying I wasn't at that
last meeting no that's fine um we've
already had this before previous on is
that even though you're weren't at the
previous meeting you are still in charge
with to vote on them doesn't mean to say
you can't you have to but you you've got
the right to vote on
them right then Chairman's brief this is
the one where I don't have much to say
normally but this I've got three points
on this one um ccer Johnson has already
printted this by saying that uh about
meeting times and that and generally we
want to keep them as concise as possible
3 hours are a long time especially
without a break um and it gets difficult
to concentrate towards the end
especially when you come towards lunch
and your tum is rumbling um so that's
the principle we'll try and keep them as
concise as possible next month we've got
several items on there um which one I
wouldn't want to move and two we can't
really move so the next meeting is
likely to go on uh to have a lunch break
and then go on after lunch in the same
way we did with the ICB when they came
in to do with own buget so if members
could make that aware if they can only
attend for partal meeting that is okay
that's fine and I'm willing to have
question um questions from those members
who can't stay after lunch um but this
is really important uh we've got some
key items on the agenda next time so if
you can say as much as possible cancel
FR you
please
we can't hear you um CC
fry if if we're going to have these
lengthy meetings and it is known that
it's going to be lengthy uh why do we
let it run into the afternoon rather
than start earlier in the
morning it's it's a difficult question
is you know getting here for 9:00 it is
difficult for some people um you know
especially if if they've got good way to
come as well um and the traffic you
know the meeting times have already been
published haven't
they um so if I'm I'm willing to be
flexible and if we have members here
already uh to go I'm can start as soon
as possible but it is very
difficult yeah yeah uh because the start
time meetings have been published they
can't start before that published time
now so osc on February can't start
before
10:00
unfortunately um sorry I don't find it
difficult starting at 9:00 no un no it's
legally it's legally what we could do
potentially is have a pre-
meeting earlier where we could discuss
we could talk about the flavor in the
principles of what's going on those
reports those
questions um but um what say about
Council KY please thanks chair yeah um
so we're got to have a long meeting next
time I'm looking at the work plan we've
got warshire County Fire and Rescue
coming I guess you're thinking that's
going to take some time um I'm not sure
that the consultation has closed by the
time they come on the 9th of February
that's the whole point okay and we've
also got orbit another fairly chunky one
might I make a suggestion that if there
are some paper ERS for reading from the
presenters prior to the meeting it could
shorten their presentations and it could
better focus our questions because if we
wait until they appear with their 20 or
30 PowerPoint slides it's always quite
difficult for us and it takes up a lot
more time so you might be able to do a
little bit of pre-work with these
presenters to cut down the amount of
time they spend at this meeting my
suggestion yeah well for some reason I
know a bit about the the fire and rescue
one um so there won't be any PowerPoint
presentation there will be a brief five
minute update or overview from the chief
R officer supported by the portfolio
hold from the County Council but the
rest of the time will be for questions
there won't be Death by PowerPoint on
that one but I take the point about
orbit again we need to make
sure very little person points just
brief points kpis Etc and then a certain
amount of time for for questions so and
if again if we can give them the
questions a lot of the questions in
advance that would hopefully shorten it
as well thank you very much chair that's
good to hear and of course with a very
firm hand from the chair I'm sure we'll
be finishing in good time but part up
meeting I'm afraid
is uh it'll be cat the passing gun will
be the firm hand when it comes to the
far and risky part so you're going to
have
yeah right so we've got councelor orock
and then councelor Wally hoggins
please oh there we go um yeah I was was
going to say very similar to that uh
prob must be three years ago last time
orbit came to this committee um their
presentation was 52 minutes
long and it left very do you remember do
you remember counselor yeah and it did
went on far whatever leaving very little
time left for the questions y so if it
is possible to contact them and give a
very strict short time
limit um then I think that would help
the meeting yeah flow a little bit
easier we have got that in hand counc
got yeah and and the chair is um it's a
different chair to last time when I came
in so and and the current chair
is will be on their case shall we
say um cat the wild Huggins please yeah
i' just like to raise a point with
regards to the start time of the
meetings that 10:00 for those move that
don't live stat Centric is is a
reasonable time for people to get here
um it also gives officers time to set up
Etc and and crucially um also it allows
those people with primary AED children
to actually get them to school and then
to come to meetings that is includes
officers and it also includes um
counselors now you may say well does
anybody have children of that age around
this table that is not the point because
whever we are in office it is our duty
bound and duty to um attract others who
may wish to seek uh election at a later
date so we have to be seen I feel to be
uh family friendly at all times I
actually think that 10 o'cl is a
reasonable time to to meet pre meetings
could happen before that but I think we
must be mindful of those and there are
those of us sitting around this table
that do have some distance to travel uh
in order to be here and I would also
suggest that to get here for meetings
that start at 9:00 the majority of the
time is sat waiting in traffic with the
with the pollution that that then
involves so uh you know I would be
reluctant to see earlier meeting times
for this it is an important meeting we
all know that I was sitting on overview
and scrutiny um committee and again you
know orbit last time around I thought it
was was a modus oper onite that their
presentation lasted for so long well
well on it uh Victoria I can tell you so
and I think that the relationship with
orbit perhaps has changed a little since
the last time they sat around this this
table and can you confirm uh chair what
the time limit is now for presentations
was it five minutes that we were
allowing that up to 10 minutes to 10 so
yeah and that and we we say stop don't
we after that so I think thank you yeah
I understand I think some valid points
there um sometimes the weather as well
that's okay in in summer but um I think
you need do need to loow you know if
next meeting's in February might be
minus 24 and uh you know you're going to
have to CW along 10 miles hour to make
sure you get here okay um so and again
people do have you know it's not just
you know grandparents or relatives or um
sometimes take their grandchildren to
school as well so yeah this I think it's
it's a fair point um
and I'd rather people get the meeting
safely even if we have to start later
than rush to get here then then have
accidents collisions are not accidents
from my far rescue hat on
collisions so hopefully slightly longer
than I thought um the next item I'll
talk about is that agenda item number
five will be uh deferred to another
meeting um due to
who the person who was
coming turned out not to be the right
person so we wanted you know we wanted
somebody who was able to answer the
questions not to say not to give us a
sales pitch and go away and say I I'll
come back to you with a question so we
thought it's better to get the right
defer it and get the right person rather
than just sit here for an hour listen to
a s pitch and saying oh I'm sorry I
can't answer that question so um there
was some slight miscommunication I think
misunderstood but when we made it clear
what we wanted the person had to
withdraw so that item going on and
there's a couple of items that we were
adding um again Mr Perks is advised that
um even though the hvo comes under
counsil
groot's
um portfolio in terms of The Refuge
Vehicles we feel it's best to come under
the agenda right number seven one the
cinate meeting so and I was told but
this right right I do apologize if it's
not that you would be willing to stay
after your cabinet question time for the
cabinet meeting apparently so oh good
so
yes I was told from a reliable source so
but I've got a smile there so which is
good and then we're adding on to the
task and finish group number item number
eight public houses we're also adding an
update from councelor Johnson on the
budget task and finish um working group
so um so we have got sort of planned and
it does make sense putting those in
different items so the Chairman's brief
wasn't quite so brief but hopefully it's
it is understand
Julie could your machine is not working
properly on
Frid is that better huh yeah yes
apologies I just want to clarify in
terms of the HBO where it it's a bit of
a joint thing because it does sit within
our our service but it's actually been
led by climate change which is actually
Susan junid and um Tony perks I believe
yeah um and I think Tony perks is coming
in as is Nigel Rock but just to clarify
it is it's one of those that you know
it's cross cutting so it's our service
but it has been led by climate change so
it's kind of all of us to be honest and
we've all been involved you just say
crosscutting not cross cutting didn't
you I did say cross cutting
yes right sorry that was the one can the
Curtis I do
apologize uh right
so Chairman's brief that's the sorted
out
platform number five how and great we
discussed that one uh and we've oh
that's kiy
yeah sorry to uh thank you chair sorry
to um sort of interrupt your flow you
move on to number five um I just wanted
to say that two things really first of
all that I was disappointed to hear that
platform were not
coming um I've sort of formed the view
over recent months that the periodic
appearance of housing associations at
this
committee um means that we are not so
regularly in touch with them as perhaps
I would like in my particular Ward we
have issues with platform um in respect
of some housing provided by per Simon I
think you're aware of that um what I my
question is um there is a task and
finish group looking at the performance
of housing associations but I noticed
it's not on the agenda so it's a
question about the inclusion of a report
from that group on the agenda which I
might direct to
Howard yeah the reason why it's not on
the agenda is because we haven't had
another meeting of the task and finish
group since the last OC me so we just
don't have an update at the moment since
last time thank you for that
clarification yeah yeah a couple things
on
that keithly sorry um you know we we saw
the beneficial effect of having the
right people in uh for alen Q last time
um so yeah it's definitely important we
got the right people here um and
hopefully will have the same when they
do come in as soon as possible it will
have the same beneficial effect it is
the councelor office residents um we we
certainly need
to um hold them to account one of the
questions I was going to ask and it was
pertinent to the task and finish group
on on ha and associations was the
completion of the
questionnaire um and N not here so I I
was going to ask that as well so is
important that we get the right people
here so so um yeah I do take on your
point and it's it's right we we do
challenge them and is start because we
are concentrating their minds on what we
want them to answer and and not them go
on for 50 50 minutes on their
presentation they are we are starting to
see more positive results or we have
already with alen Q CC wall hins please
yeah just to reassure councilor Keithley
that um the questionnaires that have
gone out is all about resetting the
relationship that all counselors have
with the housing associations and
holding them to better account really so
that we have those better lines of
communication so I think that there is
much there's been a great deal done with
that but we now just need to wait to
hear what the responses are so that we
can see what those be best practices um
are so um I I also get a sense that
they're sort of sitting up a lot
straighter now than they were hence the
uh fact that the housing provider
platform housing pulled out today
because they didn't have the right
person coming to the meeting because we
don't want the flanela we want the you
know we want people that can answer
questions and tell us about their
practices I think we need to be
heartened by the effect that the task
and finished group is perhaps already
having and what it will have so thank
you thank you for
that so moving on to item number six
it's cabinet question time and we've
already preempted that councelor grot is
going to be here um councelor grot
obviously is is part of osc we sometimes
have presentations from members and and
groups Etc um would you like to uh give
us a brief transation for a few minutes
or are you happy to go straight into
questions uh thank you councelor sorry c
um chairman um well we have submitted a
a briefing note for the um committee's
consideration um and which outlines all
the uh many many um different operations
which comes under this portol folio I
mean when I was given it I was thought
yes it's going to be bins and uh you
know dog mess and that sort of thing but
to say we cover everything from uh
public
conveniences through to um you know
obviously the contracts of the refugees
emergency planning as well which one I
wasn't aware of um of course other area
areas such as markets and environmental
health and Licensing and the thing with
these is that they do have um effect of
everybody in the district I me we had
floods a couple of weeks ago which um
Julie was very actively involved with um
you know and we um followed through to
Grounds Maintenance we have a new
contract that's going to has been
awarded um in lines with our contract um
procedure in the Constitution and we we
deliver these all to a very detailed
briefs our officers work very hard to
make sure that we support our um
residents with the services that are
discretionary and non discretionary um
but obvious two very cost effective um
um methods thank you thank you a nice
brief presentation then which is good
Danny Julie did you want to add anything
sorry Brien Council Keith I know you've
um got some question obviously we'll
talking about the HBO uh the next bit so
if you could keep your your questions at
the moment just related to the items in
the um cabinet P sorry in the in the um
agenda that's the word I was looking for
I do apologize um to start off and then
we'll go on to the hvo when we do the
cabinet meeting thanks chair yeah well
um I don't know if other members had
seen that I'd already submitted some
questions um have they been these
questions already been circulated to the
other members of the committee Howard or
would these be a surprise um the these
will the committee will be hearing them
for the first time now oh excellent okay
excellent
um so I shall I shall Park uh one or two
of them as requested by the chairman so
we can come back there parking services
you're parking that I'll be Park the key
I'll park I'm learning from you chair
I'll be parking those um right so um I'm
just going to just because I I I
submitted a number of questions so I'm
going to start I'm going to start with
um Leisure centers actually which was my
final question I think um our Leisure
centers are a significant operating cost
um and particularly in respect of of
running the the pools which I'm I'm a
great fan of actually I think having
swimming pools in the area is really
important so not suggesting that
anything should happen in that respect
but the there is a significant cost I'm
very interested to know what measures
we're taking to mitigate the costs of
these Leisure centers and how the recent
running cost trends look and how we're
predicting those costs potentially to
rise or fall so the trends and costs
over the coming years so that that was
question five you could start with that
one thank you councelor Keith Lee um
yeah we have a 10-year Leisure um
contract oh sorry can you hear me now
sorry shy and we have a 10-year Leisure
contract um which with slm limited um
and we actually get a positive
management fee out them I mean Julie
could give more detail on this if you
require um but from an environmental
Point obviously the one of the largest
carbon Footprints of the area is the
pairing of swimming pools and Leisure
centers so that is one area that we'll
be looking at under our climate um
change um
portfolio um so Den you want to take
over a bit more from the
details yes certainly I mean as luren
says we have a 10year contract
outsourced to um slm limited it's uh
should I say it's a very very good a
very robust contract it does bring us in
a management fee over that 10year period
um and it is a very positive management
fee um well in excessive two million
pounds that we received from them over
the years uh we pay we do pay some bits
we pay some repairs and maintenance we
have various contract details with them
but in terms of the service that it
actually provides um it's it's actually
very very positive and it does not cost
us money to run um in in terms of yeah
the big question is we know energy costs
have absolutely gone through the roof
and that is having an impact is that
because there's no
insulation um and that that was actually
a bad reference as well sorry I was just
thinking of the floods last week and we
had water pouring through the roof and
we're now carrying out major roof
repairs um however it's it's a very very
good contract yes it costs us some money
but you know it it certainly brings us
in profit running costs have gone up the
risk of that is on slm limited um
because they pay for the energy costs
now obviously when um when we renewed
the contract it was oh it was we renewed
it just about as covid hit so it was a
big big unknown as to what would happen
over the next 10 years and if Leisure
figures would you know if people would
come back to Leisure centers if they
come back to the gym so there was a lot
of risk involved in that contract so we
did very well to actually get such a
positive management fee offer back from
a contractor um the risk of energy costs
is on them but obviously given what's
happened if they came to us and said
look we need to talk about this we would
obviously sit down and talk to them what
I would add is that there are various
schemes coming out from the likes of
sport England government Etc whereby
they're trying to help Leisure providers
with these extra energy costs and we
work with slm to submit whatever grants
and and things we need to submit to try
and get money back towards to help th
those energy costs but you know what I
would say in terms of summary the
Leisure centers we've have five Leisure
centers that slm run for as very very
well they are a positive source of
income but more importantly than all
they're a very very positive source of
provision of health and well-being yeah
it's good to know I was you touched on
the point I was going to raise there
Julie that um that yes the risk is on
them but there's always the possibility
that that the contractor would come back
and say sorry because of
this significant increase in our running
costs we are you know we might have to
pull out or we might need to renegotiate
the contract but obviously you you're
taking that into account as part of that
so that's going do you want to follow up
counc KY or should I bring um cancel
little
in no no that's fine thank you for the
explanation that was really good I mean
I don't if any other members have got
questions about that but I'm happy to
allow you to move across to council a
littlewood I've got some more questions
afterwards
yeah thank you both uh good morning um I
was looking through the the the the the
report you have brief information in in
under item six um on the briefing note
um one of the things that you've said
several times and written here is the
contract is going very well and I have
no no doubt that's true um but there are
only two data points listed here which
really doesn't help us to understand how
things are moving forward from a
historical point of view um the
contract's been in place I think you
said three years is it now yeah so it
would be very very useful to see the
growth through that period in terms of
uh attendance
Etc yeah so if if I just come back there
if if what we did when we prepared The
Briefing was give you a couple of key
facts for kind of each bit of our
service to be honest if I'd have done
that for everything that we do it would
have been far bigger than the orbit 50
slides you know you'd have had a
document looking like this we we do have
key performance indicators for each of
our contracts they're all accessible
Lorraine sits on the um the various
meetings and has those each quarter we
also do um actually put them into our
kpis for corporate figures but yeah we
we can give you happily you know visitor
attendance figures or whatever for the
last however long you want them um but
but I wouldn't have submitted that
amount of detail into this brief but but
it's all there we can provide you with
what whatever you
want well thank you for that um I I
don't want I don't want a huge raft of
data all I want is a graph that shows it
it's simple that that would take up very
little space in this document um so and
the other question if I may have a
second uh um question uh on on the data
and this is my ignorance and I I I have
tried to look it up I couldn't find away
under the 2012 implemented 2013 act uh
where cost Ben the where the where the
calculation for the social benefit that
social value comes from could you just
um educate me on that
please yeah I think it's fair to say
that social value and and how it's
calculated seems to vary in every kind
of um organization and contract that you
actually deal with um what what I can do
is I i' I'd have to go back and pull out
the facts as to how we actually
calculate social value in terms of the
Leisure Center but it covers things like
um how many volunteers they have what
they do in the community if they use
local Workforce it's a whole range of
initiatives but I I'll I can go back and
again all of this is backed up by the
detail that comes into these figures and
I can go away and just get the further
detail for you that that we can um send
out
afterwards thank you chair that would be
very
helpful councelor Wally Huggins and then
councelor off
please yes thank you um I just want to
go to item seven on your briefing note
which is to do with markets and really
it to get a view of um I'm I'm I'm often
you know bewildered by what I read on
social media about markets and I'm
wondering why is it that strapford
District Council seems to still be the
authorizing Authority for these markets
when perhaps the Town Council might be a
better organization to take um take hold
of that and also I think that'll
probably be a question for you uh
perhaps Julie but also what the
Christmas Market was a massive success
for this town I mean it was it brought
in thousands of visitors here but again
with that um there was severe traffic
congestion around the town and I'm
wondering what are we now doing um to
try to El to obviate the travel chaos of
last year for this year I'm thinking
about Cham race week in chham they have
particular routes that uh people take
for for those events and I think we are
going to have to be really more
proactive regarding that because what we
don't want is people turning away and we
need to have sufficient car parking
spaces for them can I just give you that
whole Market in the round kind of
question thank you very much
indeed okay yeah just just to clarify
with the market contract it is a joint
operation between ourselves and the Town
Council so it isn't just us um and and
it's been like that for a few years when
we quite a few years when we did
renegotiate it two years ago to extend
the contract um it was put that you know
the Town Council could have taken it on
themselves at that point um but but it
didn't happen so it is a joint contract
between the two of us um in terms of the
uh the Victorian Market I I just say a
number of debriefs have already taken
place and I'll let Lorraine come in with
the rest of the detail on that
one thank you Julie thank you um Council
W hoggins yes obviously there were um
there was commentary about the um
Victorian Market I mean on some on some
terms it's a big success bigger better
than ever but obviously there was um
concerns about the traffic um and the
crowding and as uh Julie says her
offices are actually looking at the
operational side of the the moment
because we do need to have a a a
detailed debrief on this but moving
forward we also need to um uh consult
with ourselves and the market Forum as
well and those relative stakeholders
which is obviously the Town Council the
district council um LSD um to see what
scope should be for the Victoria Market
moving forward um because as I say we it
is getting larger um we need to think
what is best for the community obviously
for the local businesses but also for
you know visitors coming in because as
you say just people sitting on War Road
and Birmingham Road isn't really um
conducive to what we want to be you
advertising a statford district to the
outside world thank you yeah do you want
to come back on that because I've got a
point on that as well yeah it's really
is is why didn't the Town Council want
to have responsibility for the
market um I I think
it's no it was one of the proposals we
put that that it was an option we've
always done it together and and at that
point they wish as to carry on doing it
together um I I don't know it actually
wasn't under my brief when that decision
was made a couple of years ago but um
yeah they they didn't want to take it on
wholly I I think perhaps you know at the
end of the day we've got more staff more
officers perhaps more experience more
resilience so I I think it was a fact
that we got the expertise to actually
carry on doing it and assisting
it yeah so I think there's probably
capacity but also I think that there's
probably need some responsibility on
that what I'd be interested to here as
chair of OC is there's going to be a
debrief there's going to be some lessons
learned' be interesting to would like to
see that OC because obviously there was
issues regarding traffic and that's
obviously traffic Road Safety potential
Artic disease uh reputational damage
with people oh I was going to go to that
but oh flipping AIDS I can't get in um
obviously safety potentially over cading
when you see some of the pictures on on
Facebook and then the other thing as
well if we got people queuing on the the
war Road or wherever we're queuing in
that's not doing our environment any
good as well so it' be interesting to
see what what lessons have been learned
um so osc can scrutinize those to see
that we do get a better Market better
experience was the word I was looking
for for our residents so I don't think
that would be unreasonable if we could
have that uh to a future meet even if
it's only a report rather than a pres
presentation from yourselves yeah so if
I can if I can just come back just to
say I mean bear in mind it was only a
couple of weeks before Christmas um
we've already had three debriefs ands
another one actually taking place with
LSD at the minute I am in the process of
gathering all of that information
because this is a huge event and it has
huge connotations for a lot of people um
we are victims of our own
success you know it is just going so
well we've now got to look at it there
are things we can't do I can't suddenly
build lots of more car parts lots of
more roads you know Etc and and we are
struggling with the infrastructure what
what I've tasked my my various working
groups with at the minute is coming back
with the facts it's okay saying oh it
wasn't safe it was too big it was too
that we need to quantify that what
wasn't safe you know are we all agree
you know what are the actual hard facts
and when we've got the actual hard facts
we're already starting to look at right
what can we change what's possible what
does the contract say what you know what
are the consequences it's a whole whole
big area it's and and there isn't a
quick fix and a quick answer because
because of our roads and our
infrastructure it will move very very
quickly because of the fact that LSD are
already starting to sign up stores for
next next year so hence the timetable is
I've got two meetings booked in next
week with more meetings a week after as
soon as we've got to that point and
obviously my portfolio holders is
involved in that because it will be a
market Forum decision you know and an
involvement and they're involved in the
meetings we will certainly produce a
paper that can come back to this group
and we'll ultimately probably have to go
back to Cabinet but rest assured we are
absolutely looking at every single one
detail and if I'd got a quick simple
answer and fix as to you know how we
solved it I i' tell you but there isn't
one because we have become victims of
our own success with it no I was
pragmatic really really realistic to
realize that wouldn't expect something
next month um you know it's going to
take a while obviously you could say
Market forces drove that one but um but
yeah I think we you know something prior
a couple of months before the event
something later in the year some
September October um would would be good
to see that things are in place as much
as possible to mitigate as you call it
your victims of your own success and
you're taking reasonable steps to do
that uh accept that some things are
beyond your control but we might have to
think outside the box to to put
different strategies into alleviate some
of the congestion um promote Park and
Ride More where some special deals Etc
so I think it's not beyond the WID of uh
members and officers to come up with
something like that and I think we would
like to well I person would like to see
that to come forward I might be the
minority of one here um but I think it
would be a good idea to have on our work
plan just some report how this is going
because it like you say it's such a big
success and there are lots of benefits
of course but there's also lots of risks
associated with it uh right I've got uh
councelor
Ralf now please uh thank you chair I was
going to ask a question about markets
firstly I need to declare an interest um
I I am the mayor and along with
councelor OK opened the Christmas Market
I also chair the full Town Council as
mayor and I sit on the market Forum you
need to know that right uh the question
I want to ask it's not a question really
it's a shout out um to for the amazing
job that our Leisure Center does in
Stratford I have no idea and perhaps you
have no not much idea of of having sat
and chaed the support group at Stratford
what they do for the most vulnerable in
our community so the refugees they look
after the refugees they look after the
young people they do deals for young
people they do deals for older people
they are really working certainly the
Stratford one is I don't know about the
others but they are working to be very
much part of this community and I really
applaud them because they are reaching
out and working very hard with our
community and I'd like to thank them for
that yeah just again as follow up to
that yeah again we do hear about lots of
these initiatives um things to help
people make them more affordable or or
free but what I you potentially would be
good I still think we're not reaching
everybody um and whether we can whether
can involve members more to publicize
the events that are going on um
particularly for people who are
suffering you know financial hardship
whether we can publicize that more we've
all got a responsibility and and I know
people say we've got the website and
publicize things as well but I think if
we can get the message out as much as
possible that would be good it's almost
bit like the M partan sketch what the
Romans do for us you know what the
Leisure Centers do for us well they do
this they do that but we don't know
about them so if again if if it's enough
of we can help as well
so yeah if I can just come in there um
this might be a surprise to a lot of you
but my background and is actually Sport
and Leisure it's not actually bins and
waste um and and my first degree was
actually in ledure Center or Recreation
management not not waste management um
it it is yeah it's it's an age- old one
isn't it Sport and Leisure how
accessible is it can people get to it
and it's something that the Leisure
industry have been trying to address for
for a lot of years and I would say still
haven't really addressed hard to reach
groups are called hard-to-reach groups
for exactly that reason because they're
hard to reach um and and it is a
difficult one and and certainly over the
years you know the work we've done with
outlying communities with you know with
different people to a lot of people just
getting somebody that's not confident
into a Leisure Center is actually a
really really kind of hostile
threatening environment you know it's
that big scary place that you you know
there's all these people and you've got
to know all these things and you've got
to be super fit before you get there and
slm they do do a a lot of Outreach work
what we have done subject to budget
approval next year we're expanding that
with another post that that's very much
dedicated to even more Out Of Reach and
you know hard-to-reach areas where they
can take the activity to the community
they can make them more aware and
certainly what we did about oh it's
about six it's been about a year now we
now have a I have in my team a dedicated
Leisure and events and markets officer
he actually is an ex slm employee and he
sends out everything that slm are doing
and we put it out on all the social
media and get it out as far as wide as
we can because I think again there's
this recognition that because they're
they're Everyone Active they're slm
they're not part of the council and it's
not something we're doing and we've done
a lot of proactive work you know to in
fact recently it was um the armchair
exercises we we sent out everywhere so
absolutely we are doing as much as we
can to try and get those messages out we
can you know I can do more to get them
out to every counselor and say hey can
you you put this out to your to your
districts to your more vulnerable
residents as well um but you know they
are hard to reach groups for just that
reason um slm do do an awful lot in
terms of trying to drop prices but you
know I remember the time when we did the
you know we did the free swimming for
under fives and you know what it didn't
actually it didn't actually make a
difference to how many people started
coming into the Leisure centers even
though it was free so it's much wider
than just you know cost and
accessibility and it is part of the
whole heal and well-being agenda how how
do we get people more active and and you
know fundamentally if it's not fun
they're not going to do it you say
someone you you ought to go to that gym
because it's good for you it's a bit of
a turnoff but you go to that gym because
you're going to have loads of fun and
you know that's how we need to Market it
and that's that's very much what what
we're looking at but we are very
conscious of it and and yeah we we're
we're open to any more suggestions about
how we can Market more of what Everyone
Active are doing but but I do feel we've
come a long way over the last year um in
terms of actually getting those messages
out there I'll take your point about fun
that's why we've got such a full
attendance osc it's just such such a fun
event that people want to turn up to um
but yeah I think that counselors that
you have got a role to play and I think
if you can involve us as well even if
only half the councils do it we might be
tapping into a different network uh you
look at their updates and also with
their T and parish councils as well so
um yeah more than willing to help I've
got councel passing them next
please uh my question is about the
energy costs at the Leisure
centers um slm are responsible for
providing the the heating and and so on
and so and it it's in their interest to
reduce the energy costs and the district
council is responsible for the fabric um
uh but it it there's no incentive
financially for us to improve the
insulation and the the uh perhaps put
solar panels on the roof to heat the the
water with so uh but there are these
grants you you think are going to be
available for improving Leisure centers
so who's going to take responsibility
for um for getting these grants and
because it is important in terms of
reducing carbon emissions and uh for for
the district council so H how is that
going to work work I know there's
several want to answer that I know can
grot well I know I've got can I should
have introduced canc I know he doesn't
need any introduction but C the rock is
here and I'm sure you'll be able to talk
about the infrastructure as well but the
if you want to come in first and then
Nigel if you only to come in to add on
about the infrastructure Etc on on
public buildings sorry thank you um yeah
I was probably going to say what Niger
would be um probably say say better is
the fact that we're not looking at you
know reduction just to sort of save
money this is part of our commitments to
reducing our carbon Footprints and um
you know increasing environment friendly
so this is going to be coming under the
climate um portfolio and it's something
we're going to be actively pursuing so
I'll I'll hand over to to
councelor am on oh there we go thank you
chairman yeah um clearly this is uh is
the leadest portfolio is is climate
change uh but I've I've also got
property as well uh and it's one of
the the things we're very interested in
if you look down the
list uh Leisure centers is is one of the
high emitters of carbon um and uh we
have already started on looking at that
um uh councelor junor has um been
working with uh uh Ellen our our climate
change officer there's a couple of
strands at that and uh one is to look at
the actual uh Energy Systems within
their the heating systems such as there
are to see if they can be made more
efficient uh I'm not actually got that
detail more tony perks may be able to
add to that and clearly some of these
buildings and I've spend a little time
on Google Maps looking at buildings to
see what we can do about solar PV on on
the roofs and the car parks and uh uh
solar shelters for instance it's a
series of options um many of these
things not to be look at
concept
um there's a river next to to uh the
Leisure Center in Stratford which is
something I've been involved in the
previous life is looking at the capacity
of of rivers to provide either uh heat
or indeed uh energy from flow so there
are lots lots of work in Pro progress
over the next years and we will be
providing a budget for that should uh
Council uh agree with the budget that
we're putting forward or come come come
across with amendments that don't
interfere with that so uh it it is well
on the program uh to deal with that uh
both in the change uh program that we're
putting forward or in the existing uh
portfolio for change but I think if if
you need more detail Tony perks will
know about the premises more than I
would I just wonder whether Mr P would
be able to perhaps send a briefing that
round um in terms obviously the be's
going on a bit whether you just some
briefing note so people got some facts
and figures what we're likely to be
doing yeah very happy to do that I'll
ask Skelly Warren who's our climate
Champion who's leading on this to do
that but yeah the Things N describes are
all sort of accurate we're looking at
sort of um solar or solar water or
photov volti arrays on the roofs
particularly because there's some
government funding available for that so
we we're we working up the detailed
proposals of that to present to Cabinet
handing glove with that goes before you
s of put Renewables on a roof you should
look at the insulation levels on it so
there'll be sort of a fabric assessment
Carri as part of that process but I can
get Ellie to issue a a general sort of
briefing out members find that helpful
thank you very much uh follow counc
passing on then so presumably uh we'll
be able to renegotiate the contract with
slm because they'll have the reduced um
cost of their heat and they'll be able
to contribute to the cost of the
district
council um it's a process that we're
doing in partnership with slm because as
you're right we don't want to spend a
lot of sort of District Council money um
to facilitate the saving for a
contractor in reality a lot of the money
comes from central government with a
view to saving money from that sector so
there will be a contractual
consideration as part of that but
because of the situation with the Ledger
centers we can't do it without slm so
we're working in partnership with them
to deliver hopefully a mutually
beneficial solution and potentially we
increase in the value of the asset yes
although I don't think anybody would buy
it from us yeah oh might buy it but not
keep it for its original purpose I think
we on uh Council fragile please got you
on the list
next thank you chair I was hoping to
mention this a while ago but um not left
behind um and it's to do with the
traffic uh coming living south of the
river coming from the south and most of
the traffic that's coming through is not
actually going into the town it wants to
get through the town and this was
specifically
noticeable uh during the the Victorian
Fair because most of the people stacking
up on banby road uh were lores and
lorries had no intention of going into
the town tener they want to get through
it so so we've got we've got to find
some ways of making sure that
lores have an alternative way to get
around the outside of Stratford rather
than having to go through the center so
yeah I don't think 100% falls under C of
cow Cuts I can understand there's a bit
of a link there when it comes to the
market and congestion so I think there's
there's a couple of things I think we'll
have to one raise that point with
another portfolio hold down but again on
that list of things Julie for the um the
de debrief again how do we discourage or
make sure that lorries don't come and
add to the congestion when we've got the
the market so there's a bit of a tenuous
link there could say from a traffic
point of view we' done it in a
roundabout way but we'll
um oh come on come on you're a bit slow
today well I'm sure I'm sure counc goart
will sympathize with me because she
lives out of the river as well and must
have experienced it yeah I think the
fact that we've got the deputy leader
and a portfolio holder here and other
portfolio holders um here and and the
chairperson of the council as well it
will be noted so I think that the point
is is
right yeah right so I've got uh cancel
Wy hoggins again if you want to come in
please yeah thank you councelor Gro uh
what's been your biggest challenge as a
newly elected counselor um combined with
being a newly appointed portfolio holder
and also the followup question with that
is which bit of your portfolio because
it's quite detailed and it's very person
Centric um which bit of your P portfolio
concerns you the most concern might not
be the right word but which bit of that
worries or perhaps keeps you awake at
night the most but it's a two-prong
attack be biggest challenge coming into
post and
what yeah all right thank thank
you thank you councelor W Hawkins um
Julie just said the probably the most
biggest challenge is working with her
which is what we were laughing about
yeah I agree
definitely yeah um yeah I mean this has
been very challenging obviously coming
in as a new counselor we had lots of new
counselors in May and um we have enjoyed
looking at everything with fresh eyes um
and we also have a much younger cohort
now um on your side we have some young
counselors as well and is it's very
refreshing to see um people with
different ideas and a different
perspective on things so it has been
interesting I mean everybody's strength
is their weakness and the fact is I've
come in completely fresh means I have no
I've got no there's no I've got no you
know sort of skellingtons in the C I've
got no knows nothing to live down got
plenty to live up that's not what I've
heard against the grro okay maybe maybe
not maybe not you know you come in with
plenty to live up to but not too much to
live down when you're new into it um I
think that the biggest challenges
looking at the portfolio going through
is think really is where it comes into
environmental and um you know and
climate change it ties into it I mean
obviously as we'll be discussing um
later the waste and recycling I mean
it's back to the old depes mode
everything counts in large amounts and
we can't just keep on throwing things
your age away there coun grot sorry
sorry give your age away oh
sorry yeah indeed indeed um so you know
with things becoming much much more
crucial on what happens with our waste
stream and how it impacts the
environment we have to be much more
aware so this is where I mean my main
concerns are on medium to long term um
for taking the portfolio forwarded don't
that's good or bad news for Julie but um
know these are these are very much um
our priorities as a council and um as a
as a group uh sorry what was the rest of
the questions it was very much getting
to know me wasn't it
yeah yeah I could say um at the moment
um the concerns I suppose really
um I suppose it's where we tie into the
general infrastructure it's car parking
when it comes into town because it's we
are operating car Parks throughout the
area um the whole District but where it
comes the people is say we have this
influx of people they want to shop they
want to um attend the uh the markets we
also have a lot of residents in the town
who have to have on street parking and
have more than one or two cars so so we
do have a lot of issues with where
people could put their cars when they
come in um to visit or when they come in
because they live here and it's a case
that we talk of new initiatives like the
um Gateway project I mean you know we
want to have parking there but is should
we be encouraging more people to come
into the town when they visit in their
cars and that that's that's probably
where we um look where my concerns are
in a strategic thing I mean maybe that
me we need to work with the County
Council because obviously we've got a
park and ride which may be utilized more
we may need to look at more you know our
long-term in you know um you know sort
of active um travel for the residents of
the district um but we also need to make
sure that we're not inadvertently
encouraging more cars in um at every
opportunity um so that's that's my re so
thank you for that I thought councelor
grot you you doing a request to
councelor rock is is you want some more
work is the peso would say you just
can't get
enough I tell you see people people set
me off that's a trouble yeah right um
I've got uh councelor I I'll bring you
in next you haven't spoken and then I've
got councelor littlewood and councelor
ke oh okay can come back in again a yeah
um I've got two questions actually the
first is not at all topical uh what what
lessons were learned from the no mo
may uh campaign if you perhaps call it
that uh last May and what will um result
from those this
may okay if um if I just say that we
didn't actually do no more may last year
um it's not it wasn't part of our
current contract it happened in one or
two parishes I believe at their request
to the County Council a lot of the
mowing that we do is not of our land it
is of County Council land um and
ultimately we do what what they ask us
to do so if we get a request saying will
you do this or whatever we need their
approval because it's not our land we
contract on their behalf in terms of
going forward um Kate sat there because
she was part of it um about all I can't
remember it was about a year ago we did
have a working party that looked at what
should go into the new grounds
maintenance contract because we were
just right in the spec at that time and
we sat in this room with County council
with various counselors from the various
parties to actually look at what we
wanted to do going forward um and I
think it is listed on the briefing note
we have and we did agree a few changes
from that there weren't huge changes
that we could actually make but no moay
was one of them that we talked about
coming forward
and we have arranged so our new contract
starts on the 1st of April with a with a
new contractor Continental Landscapes we
have arranged a cross party um briefing
note that that invites have already gone
out for a meeting to actually explain to
you what will happen in the in the new
contract and what has changed knowing
that the you know the real key factors
are things like no M wildf flower
planting use of
glyphosat-prozess you know we've we've
taken that all into consideration as as
to what is wanted we do work very
closely with the county because one of
the things we've done is reduce the
number of cuts on the grass burges at
counties agreement because that's what
they wanted so again it's you know we in
all of these things whatever it is
there's a number of us or a number of
organizations um that work
together second one C the r please thank
you uh yeah the second one and I'm not
sure whether this comes um into uh uh
Lorraine's
portfolio um and I'm rather springing it
on you I guess um plane pitch strategy
my understanding is Stratford in fact I
think South warshire doesn't have one
and and it's been dragging on for
several years and I'm just
wondering um what if anything is
happening if this comes under your
portfolio Mr P want to come in I think
it's somebody else's portfolio yeah that
comes under the planning Port planning
policy
portfolio
um I don't think it's quite right to say
we don't have a playing pit strategy at
all there is some debate with the fa
about sort of the status of our playing
pitch Str I'm very happy to take that
with you outside but I'd need John
kord's advice on that one to sort of get
you the latest situation cancel I but it
it doesn't fall under canselor grow cost
portfolio Okay thank you yes I would
appreciate that because I've been told
that without such
a perhaps better formula Rel ated
strategy it's not possible to apply for
Grants from bodies such as sport
England um yes without wishing to get
into too much D talk it's on the edge of
my area of expertise the planing pitch
strategy is determined by sort of the
housing growth strategy you have for the
area we have a a plan pitch strategy but
it will need to be revised as part of
the South forer local plan and a little
bit chicken and egg until we've agreed
the numbers in the local plan we can't
particularly produce a plane pitch
strategy and it's been a while since the
SE those has been carried out I think we
did an update to the last one to make it
current which should get us around that
situation but I'm H so I'm happy to
discuss the detail of that with you at a
separate time okay thank you canc R
please just as a point of information I
I am aware that uh successful grants
have been made to the fa for uh playing
pitches because there was one done in my
ward it was a right old carryon actually
but they they they did get the money in
the end
I'd be very interested to know
more yeah no that's a good point um
councilor keithy obviously going back to
your five questions I know some of them
we're going to talk about in a bit yes
thank you chair I mean many of them been
covered um I do feel that councelor Rice
might have kicked my final question into
the long
grass I was going to ask because we are
all familiar with ID verie I was going
to ask about the new contract to
Continental Landscapes Julie you've
already said there'd be some sort of
briefing note but could you just give us
a really quick overview of of of you
know how we've arrived at changing the
contract and are we confident that they
are the quality of contractor we want
will they be using battery powered tools
s such like um I know that you've
already touched on a briefing I don't
know when that will come out but maybe
you'll say a few words for everybody
because it is a change thank
you yeah answer the question how they do
it and what they do it is is actually we
put that out in the specification so to
start from the beginning we we have
procured through a very robust and very
thorough procurement process the start
of that was actually right in the
specification as to what do we want
going forward which is why we formed the
working group that Kate and various
councilors at the time sat in because
before a contractor can bid we have to
tell them you know we have to know what
we want them to bid on so we put in the
contract things like whether we want
them to use electric mowers or you know
what sort of things we want or in some
cases like we did in this one we say you
need to minimize your CO2 you know
output how are you going to do that and
they come back with the suggestions so
we write the specification we put it out
to Tender we go through hundreds of
clarification questions there's a formal
tender submission process and a formal
evaluation process um we actually had I
I'm trying to say I think it was seven
bids that we actually had and and I'm
talking about documentation that's this
thick so we have an evaluation panel
that goes through all the documentation
and we took four I I can't remember
whether it it's three or four through to
the next stage and then they put their
final bids in and we evaluate them based
on preset criteria quality versus
quantity um and and we scored them
accordingly um and it was very close and
and that's how Continental were the
highest scorers we then took up
references and I took those up
personally with a number of of other
contract with a number of other
counselors as to how they actually
performed so in terms of what they do
the electric vehicles those bits we
specify that to to some extent um in
terms of you know quality yes it's
always a risk when you change a
contractor um I I will say that a lot of
the existing staff of tpit over so
although the company name might have
changed the actual stuff with a lot of
the experience will go will stay stay
with the new company um but but you know
I think it's um I think it's very
important that we as a council actually
show we're not scared to change you know
actually the easiest solution might have
been to stay with with who we were with
because well you kind of think it's safe
but you know it's a very fair and robust
process and Continental were were you
know it was the better bid and the
better winners with the references
backed up um time will tell but we we've
had a number of very good mobilization
meetings already with Continental um and
and I'm very confident that that they
will perform
accordingly yeah well thank you for that
that's really uh useful and um provide
some reassurance for us all that this is
going to be a good decision for us thank
you Julie yeah I'll bring ker off in in
just two seconds I've just got a brief
follow up on that um one of the
questions I was going to ask was about
teething troubles when you change
contractors and obviously if lots of
them are cheed across they know the area
and they don't have to real arm Ms Etc
um one of the
things you you mentioned about electric
mowers and if we go down the no mo may
and we have a really wet humid Mild
May we could potentially have grass
that's 2 foot high would the electric
mowers be able to cope with such
conditions
and again that's one where I go back to
you know what what we state in the
contract at the end of the day we say to
the contractor this is what we want and
they have to make sure it works now I
was actually head of service at War when
they bought in all their electric mowers
and also cut the amount of you know cut
the amount of cuts sorry that they
actually did and yes it absolutely
caused those problems because the
electric mowers aren't as powerful and
couldn't deal with you know the length
of grass so so to be honest you know
we're good in our portfolio but as last
week it you know showed we can't control
the weather so if it does happen and we
get you know that lengthy Gras we you
know that we will say to the contractors
right you know what are you doing about
this if they are using electric mowers
then you know there's always the
opportunity they bring in you know
different mowers to get over that
problem at that time because it's always
dependent on kind of those situations so
you know we we work very very well with
our contract
and and we solve the problems as they
arise accordingly um at absolutely
minimum cost and minimal disruption
whenever they
arise so I I know um hav worked at
District Council War I did know about
that and also did see the effects down
the Rugby Road in particular in in
lemington where um you know we thought
we might as well been high baing the
residents alonger um and long say it is
is obviously consequences of actions
isn't there so you we specify things so
things don't always um work to work to
plan so yeah flexibility and as you know
about the flooding I know about that
certainly uh councelor Ralph please uh
yes so I was on that working group and
one of the um biggest concerns that I
have and I think most of the counselors
around this table have with their
residents is when they cut the verges
outside their houses so the option is to
blow the grass back onto the pavement or
blow the grass into the uh guttering uh
both have consequences you you put it
into the guttering you block up the
guttering and you have flooding issues
you blow it onto the pavement it rains
and you have people falling over because
it's very slippery uh there is a third
option of course is to actually suck it
all up and take it away but I gather
that's very expensive so do we know
which option is going to be used with
these new contractors
cuz it actually sounds Petty but it's
very very important to my residents I
live in a road where there is a pavement
and then averge and the people that slip
over when it comes back onto the
pavement is quite
big yeah when we as I say we have
arranged um a working group to explain
kind of what will happen going forward
and I think actually that's quite soon
I'm trying it is in the calendar so when
we go into that meeting we'll make sure
that we answer those questions and what
I'll actually do is put out a note to
cabinet members and counselors saying
beforehand if you've got any other
questions if you can let us know them
beforehand yeah and we can make sure
that we build them into that
presentation because I'm sure you'll
appreciate we're dealing with a very big
specification and and we wouldn't in you
know intend to go into that that kind of
meeting trying to tell you every single
line of everything that's going to
happen but we will will answer that one
at that that group yeah
absolutely any other questions I I might
as well finish then um trying to finish
with a pun uh just a couple of things
obviously the markets was a really big
successful event and I assume um it had
a positive effect on our car parking
income so that would be over us be
interesting to see how the overall
position is likely to be looking um for
for the outturn and then just a brief
update on how many of our over over 65
parking permits have we have we sent
sold 110
110 thank you and so yeah but you're
likely to have a you the market is
likely to had a positive effect on the
um the car parking I can confirm that
market to car parking income was
exceptional um it was very very good and
and going back to the debrief you know
that's one of the the consequences
should we decide to change things going
forward it you know actually it's a big
source of income to both ourselves in
the car parks and I believe the
businesses because a lot of the feedback
I got was that they they were very very
busy um so yes it was exceptionally High
We compared it with last year's income
um obviously we canceled one day because
of the snow last year and it was well
above each day from last year couldn't
compare it with previous years because
of covid but yes it was very very
positive right I can't any other
questions um thank you for uh being
subject to the interrogation and and the
references to to PES mode uh far too
young the rain of course I'm sure you
are you you must have watched it on God
or catch off or top of the pops review
um so thank you for that um we'll we'll
give you a brief uh uh rest F so I don't
think we'll we'll be seeing you now for
for another year um but you never know
if if if we got something that comes up
uh thank you k loock for your points in
addition to that some clarification um
I'm just proposing that we've been going
for a for an hour and quarter and we've
um whether we have a small bright wild
CS the grot and Julie um M Oh no you're
staying aren't you you're staying so
well
yeah um um whether we have a smaller
break for 5 minutes um so we can then go
on to the item number seven the cabin
meeting of the 15th of January so thank
you for
that
right then uh thank you um ladies and
gentlemen we'll um we'll get started
again now
please right then
we'll now go on to item seven cabinet
meeting on the 15th of January
2024 um we'll be considering a couple
items off this uh first item we were
going to do is the community and medical
facility
operon I need to declare an interest and
I'm sorry because I'm sit on overie and
scrutiny at County on the health overie
and scoy and and it's a subject that is
brought up
there so it's a non-pecuniary interest
yeah councelor
Johnson I have to make a similar
interest that I'm also on the Adult
Services overview and scrutiny committee
and I represent this Council on there um
I need also I think to declare that I
with other members of this Council and
others received a long email from a
group representing a number of Parish
councils with interests uh around up
aite all um and they have raised some
concerns which I'll mention in the
discussion great nice thank you again
it's a non-pecuniary interest and you'll
be taking part in the debate yep thank
you any other
interests no right then Mr PKS do you
want to give us a a briefing please just
a brief briefing please bear with me
it'll take a few minutes but it will be
worth it I assure you oh is oh is Mr but
yeah if I can just sort of get through
it then I think every you'll have a bit
more context of what it is um we are as
part of our local plan seeking to
deliver a new settlement at upper light
horn um it's a significant s of
development will sort of produce the
second largest town in The District in
terms of scale it'll be bigger than
shipston and ol and that one in terms of
population perhaps not in terms of scale
when it's concluded so it's quite a
significant sort of undertaking that we
made and back when we granted the
outline consent for that we entered into
a section 106 agreement which saw the
infrastructure for the development
provided once a certain number of houses
had been
constructed um the development's been
taken forward by two developers um a
conglomerate called ceg and a sort of a
section of the site has been delivered
by homes England and they're using sort
of the different flags of different
developers to to build those at B Vis on
site for example working on the ceg side
we are approaching the point in the
process where the section 106
requirements start to trigger and
through the section 106 agreement from
the site we will get a number of things
we will get a Village Center which is of
like a supermarket s of shops um basic
facilities that a village would expect
to see that's being delivered by the
Hinton group on behalf of the two
developers and the master plan for that
is out for consultation at the moment so
the the detailed design for that will
sort of follow the the master planning
process there are also um section 106
Provisions for a primary school which
will be delivered by the the education
Authority so that that's sort of
starting to sort of come to life now and
as a district council we've got an
obligation to deliver a community center
on the
site the other two major s of parts of
the section 106 I I won't go through the
whole detail but the ones that are
relevant today are there is a
requirement to provide a a GP practice
through Medical Center on the site and
there is an option for the police to
have a presence for the safer
neighborhood team on the side um as I
say we're getting now to sort of the tri
triggers well there are enough units on
site that we need to start working out
how we build these they're due for
delivery depending on buildout in about
2 to 3 years time so I've undertaken a
sort of project to look at how we would
meet Our obligation to provide the
community center and we were also
entered into dialogue partly through
this group that counc Johnson refers to
um with the integrated care board who
have the responsibility for delivering
the GP practice on the site during the
course of last year the integrated care
board undertook a public consultation
exercise which they're required to do
under their constitution to S of work
out whether the provision should be on
the site or whether it should be sort of
accommodated within neighboring GP
practices and the result of that
consultation was that the provision
should be made on the site and we
entered into discussions with the ICB
about would it be more effective for us
to provide three individual projects or
would it be more um economic to the
public purse if we sort of club together
and built a a single building for sort
of two uses the initial attractions for
that was you have a single contractor
single set of preliminaries we can share
some common space like Adventure tools
toilets and that sort of thing there
there seem to be a logic for that the
section 10 106 agreement contains of
very basic details about what these
facilities should sort of contain
there's a a floor area requirement and
there is a budget allocated to each
which goes up by indexation BAS B on CPI
rather than construction prices um so we
were faced with the situation where we
we'd got a a vague requirement of what
we needed to do a vague sum of money
um and to S move that forward I've
commission the report that's sort of
before you today that we presented at
the cabinet on Monday to look at how we
could s start to shape this and turn
this into a tangible project that we
could deliver in accordance with our in
line with our section M6
requirements um
the three parties that have contributed
to the report ourselves the police and
the integrated care board and what the
report explores is is it practical to
deliver a a single sort of development
that would provide facilities for the
health the police and ourselves could we
do that within budget and is it a
sensible thing to do um um you've had a
chance to sort of look at the report I'm
happy to take you through any details of
the report we we tendered that project
hand projects won it and they've carried
out an analysis based on some quantity
surveying some public consultation um
some reviews of similar projects and
broadly that they've concluded that in
principle at least it makes sense to
work together with the ICB to deliver
this there should be savings for both of
us and the good news is that the project
should be deliverable within the budget
that we've got available so that's all
all quite good news and what I'm seeking
um agreement from the cabinet on on
Monday which is what we're here to talk
about today
is firstly that they endorse the
report um the options the cabinet have
they can't avoid or as a council the
cabinet representing you we can't avoid
building the community center we have a
106 obligation to do that we have a
budget and we we've signed a legal
undertaking that will produce that at
the moment we have no obligation to
provide a facility for health on the
site we could leave that to the ICB and
so sort of just get on with it um but
what we're proposing in sort of the SP I
suppose of providing public service is
that we work with the integrated care
board to produce a joint building um for
the development at uper lighton which is
one of our new communities so we've um
explored that with them it seems that
the concept of a joint building is
sensible the police are also interested
in taking space there for the safer
neighborhood team so what I'm seeking
agreement from the cabinet from on
Monday is first they endorse the report
that Tander have produced secondly that
they give me in principal agreement to
work with the um the ICB and the police
to take this from a twinkle in our eye
to sort of a concept design I've asked
to move to reer stage two which is a
concept design um so we can get sort of
a firm cost a detailed design of a
building and then I to bring that back
to Cabinet before sort of pressing the
button to do anything so at that stage
we can say well is this a sensible thing
to do or is it too risky for the
district council but I I'm seeking
consent to go to the next stage so we
can firm this up with a view to saying
do we want to build a joint facility or
do we want to go our separate ways and
so that's a very brief summary of things
happy to take any
questions oh sorry the one other thing I
was going to cover is um the group that
councelor Johnson mentioned which I sure
may have approached many of you and
you'll he from in the future if you
don't know um there was a group of um I
think it's 24 Parish councils who are
quite interested in this I I met with
them with councelor rock just before the
meeting to sort of run through the
report they I think it's fair to say
have concerns that the ICB are looking
to not deliver Health Facilities on the
site um I I can't give a view on that
we've asked the ICB and that they assure
us that they they're going to S GP
provision on there we they've worked
sort of positively with us um and the
intention is to work together to deliver
that but yes we are aware of that group
and we are communicating with that group
and so I met them at 9:00 this morning
so that they're up to speed with the
report
and then I understand they're not going
to make any representations to Cabinet
on Monday following the the discussion I
had with them before this
meeting I've got councelor R and
councelor Johnson please two very brief
questions do we commission the architect
to design and also um obviously the
building needs planning permission does
it
not um yes under the proposal that we've
got at the moment we would certainly
commission the architecture design the
concept we have funding to cover the
cost of that from the 106 agreement
there was a design payment that we've
already triggered with the houses that
have been produced so we now have a
working budget to produce a design for
that but yeah under the proposal that's
being presented to Cabinet the district
council would commission the architect
to design the concept for the building
um and yes the building would require
detailed planning permission um the
planning status of it is it's it's
included within the outline planning but
the detailed design of the Village
Center where the um GP practice and the
community center would sit hasn't yet
been determined in fact the the final
design of that is being worked up at the
moment we will be allocated a plot
within the Village Center and onto that
we will need to put a a building so that
there are a few steps to go yet but yes
it would require detailed planning Miss
project
construction C Johnson please my
question uh just a matter of fact really
could um I'd be reminded of where RBA
stage two gets to is that planning
consent no that's prior to planning CER
rb2 is the end of concept design so at
that point we would have a a layout
drawing probably some sort of basic
elevations for it sufficient to give us
a sort of much more detailed cost model
but we wouldn't have detailed technical
design and we would planning would
normally come at the end of reer stage
three
kov yes very interesting uh can I can I
also make a play that that whoever does
the drawing includes some outdoor space
something community centers desperately
need and something community centers a
lot don't have and fight for kind of
outdoor space because if it's going to
be used properly as a community center
have you know play groups Etc where
people will need to work outside so can
it include some outdoor space thank
you yeah we've currently at the stage of
contribution to the consultation to the
master plan for the Village Center that
is one of the points that we've raised
to the the master planers that we are we
we we've raised the points that
potentially we would like to combine the
sits for the medical facility and the
community center and we think that
access to outdoor space for both of
those areas is important so I can't
confirm the result I get but we we've
raised that so
far yep I think else I've got a couple
of points I'd like to raise but canc
Johnson why don't you save me um
I'm I'm going to refer to the notes I've
received um you may recall when the
Integrated Health Board were here um the
discussion was dominated by the future
of Ellen Badger and I had wanted to ask
a couple of questions of the ihp got
timed out um I think the two things from
the note um I've had is firstly what
experience of Tandem projects have of
developing health heal
facilities um they refer to NHS guidance
in the text rather than saying we've
done lots of these before um the second
point is more for the ihb I guess and
you may rule me out of order but the uh
we understood the ihb was in the process
of um identifying the um GP practice
which was going to work on this and I
was going to ask the question of what
the timetable for that was and when will
that process be
concluded I guess because you've already
had the conversation that's referred to
in the note that I've had um these may
already have been
covered you you we do discuss it this
morning we're very happy to share it
with this group here as well um in terms
of tandon's experience of working on
Health Facilities my understanding is
that they have got some experience of
working on health facilities but it's
unlikely that we would use tandem to
design it anyway we commissioned tandem
for a feasibility study which theyve got
a lot of experience of doing feasibility
studies we would render um the of design
and management package going forward so
I wouldn't necessarily see Tander being
a firm that was skilled to do detail
design of a medical facility so I think
that that's a fair comment in terms of
the ICB and the procurement of the GP
practice
um there are diverging views on how this
should be done I think it's fair to say
the ICB um in our discussions with them
have two delivery models for GP
facilities they have a sort of a public
sector owned GP model where the building
remains in the public sector and there
are certain types of GPS who then rent
the space and just provide GP facilities
and I'm happy to engage on that basis in
the alternative there is the model where
the ICB just commissioner GP to sort of
develop a building which then becomes an
asset that sits within the the GP
partnership whatever business
Arrangements they have and they provide
facilities from that so there's almost
like what I've described as a bit of a
fork in the road now if we as a district
council prepared to enter a joint
building with them then it takes you
down the publicly owned route which
attracts sort of certain types of GP and
they would Appo they would approach that
type of GP to run the practice if we
choose not to take this option and the
one of the options of the cabinet on
Monday is to say no thanks don't want to
build this we just build our community
center that would take the ICB and down
a different route
and what they're telling us is that they
can't sort of procure a GP partner until
they know which route they're going to
go down this i' I've asked for
confirmation of this this morning but my
understanding with the ICB is this a
parallel well this report will be put to
their board in parallel on the 17th of
January and if the cabinet should agree
to Joint project on the ICB agreed to do
a joint project at that point we'll know
which direction we're going and we would
the ICB would then procure a GP practice
to suit that Arrangement but if it goes
the other way they' probably go in a
different direction so that's my
understanding that's the understanding I
shared with the group this morning as
well
so I think canc Ro s I've just noticed
that canc Ro want to come in in briefly
and then I'll bring ccor W hogins in yes
uh Tony perks has gone through all the
details uh for those
uh that are not uh in the east of the
district and might be wondering why 24
parishes have got what an active group
that are involved in that um the concern
that has started from the outset is that
as this uh new settlement
increases and the dwellings become
occupied there's been a spill out into
the surrounding communities in terms of
pressure on GP practices so this is a
much wider report than the GP practices
but that has become the controversial
element as the GP practices in the
surrounding communities have become and
they're all under pressure aren't they
to get GP practices but that is the
concern hence that consultation and and
the decision to go forward and create a
new practice within the settlement and
I'll have to say um you know we're
looking at the local plan the local plan
is very likely because of the housing
numbers I don't want to say are
inflicted upon us but the housing
numbers that whatever government is
brings in is like to mean more growth
this is a challenge we're likely to face
and this is a good example of some of
those
challenges but that that the that's the
reason these 24 parishes are involved in
it and um Council of Gest is sitting
over there some of those parishes that
are in our Ward uh are included in
that the decision we're looking at here
is is an enabler for the ICB to go
forward and make their decision about
which practice to award that to now I
think we would all like to
be more involved and encourage the IB to
take that decision early but they they
want us to be able to show are willing
to make that available the key thing
here is that we appear to be able to get
much better return for the tax
doing that collectively with these three
the community center the police and the
NHS all together but what I I can't
emphasize enough is that he is's up to
the Health Service through the ICB to
make the arrangements for who's going to
operate it that's not in our gift so uh
what we can do
is be an enabler for them and to I don't
say put the pressure on them but to
clear their way forward for them we've
had a whole series of meetings with them
and I have to say with uh the Member of
Parliament sir Jeremy Wright to to to
make clear that we're trying to do the
whole thing together in a collaborative
way uh and um I think that we've had
those discussions with that that group
of of Representatives of the 24 parishes
that's information for the scrutiny
committee which may not otherwise wonder
what we're talking about thank
you counc Wally hogins please yeah I
understand that only the GP practice in
harur and Bishop zton have been
consulted on this at the at the present
time and I'm wondering um what we can do
what influence uh statford District can
do to ensure that other GP practices are
consulted and I suppose the other reason
I'm going to say this is I can't see
that there's any purpose to delay any
matters you know I think cabinet you've
got no choice other than to say yes
we'll go through with this because as
you say any more delays with this just
hampers um hampers the the provision
that that is that is needed but also
Council Rock You said that uh you know
it's much better provision is and return
is needed for the taxpayer I'll probably
be coming on to that later uh but also
what um there are similarities here
between the shipston on stow and um and
over in the East and the simil
similarities are this that the GP
practices are finding that the know
costs of getting involved in this are
almost prohibitive and go up on a
monthly basis and it is really thinking
about is there sufficient money in
funding wherever that may be within the
Council budget to ensure that this can
be backed up so that there aren't delays
due to due to financing costs going up
for those that wish to take to take part
that's my big issue here is that this is
and for those in shipston you
know they need that return for the taxes
that they pay and there is nothing more
fundamental than what is before us here
proposal uh in the east of the district
thank
you
Mr again um yeah just take two points in
order um in terms of Consulting the GP
practices we haven't done a formal
consultation of GP practices we were
approached by Harbor in Bishop sington
but I think it's so that has been
included in the report but the M ICB
must just s not to do a formal
consultation with the GP practices
because that's that's their issue not
ours so there will be in the next stage
of the report a proper consultation with
the appointed g p practice to shape the
concept designed to make sure it's
deliverable and and works within that in
terms of the funding we have got a
provision a couple of Provisions sort of
within the
report at the back end about sort of if
we end up with this funding shortfall
either there are two risks I see as
funding shortfalls here there's a
short-term funding shortfall
I don't wish to malign homes England but
they're somewhat behind the delivery of
ceg on their side so we may end up with
a requirement to put up the GP building
before we've got the homes England one
of six contributions so we may have a a
gap there and there's a section about
how we might deal with that in the
report there's also the cost overrun
sort of side and if there is any cost
overrun beyond the section 106 agreement
money from the health side that's
something a
Council we I doubt we could legally find
it probably be ultra varies um what we
looked at as a model here is we could
sort of borrow the money and sort of
fund that but on the basis there was a
legal agreement in place that the ICB
played us a rent that covered the cost
of servicing and repaying that debt over
a reasonable period of time so that's
the model that we're looking at should
we end up sort of short of money when
we've got a detailed design for this so
we've tried to think that through and
sort of put mechanisms in place that can
C that should did
arise passing
please uh you've you've said that there
are two models that the I that the
ICB um uh use for working with GP
practices but neither of those seem to
worked in
shipston uh and the the the whole
situation has um been delayed and
delayed and delayed and now there's
still half a million pounds of Cil money
which is just sitting there and nobody
seems to be able to use it for a new
medical center for the GPS are you are
you concerned that might happen if you
work with the ICB in
Lor I I think the situations different
sufficiently different this is a new
community where we've been looking to
create a new GP practice whereas in
shipston its sort of expansion and
relocating an existing practice I I
think there are a significant difference
is there and I have met with a different
brunch of the NHS odly at the start of
the week and I'm I'm hopeful that we can
get a more positive solution for ships
and so I hope I hope that hasn't we
haven't given up on that um but that's
probably for another meeting
so
I looking at the that in the context of
this report what we're asking for isn't
for the district council to take on the
per of GPS it's to produce a building in
which GPS could sit funded by section
106 so whilst there is always a risk of
getting GPS to move into thing that risk
sits with the ICB and is a
responsibility of that I don't think
having sort of reflected on what you've
asked me that there's anything that
should necessarily concern you in this
cabinet report relating to that topic if
that helps but it it doesn't mean that
we won't have to work hard to get GPS in
to take that
point thank you um yeah my my question
relates
to uh the timeline
in the report 1.6 it
says uh I've been included for the key
next steps required to maintain momentum
we estimate that a fully functioning
facility can be achieved by quarter 4
2026 IE about two years from now so
there's a couple of things on that
one definition of folly
functioning
to if we're going go a joint project
with the
ICB have they got similar time scales
and funding availability would they be
able to mix and anecdotally I've been
told that sometimes the governance
procedures models can add delays into
processes whether that's true or not I
don't know um so
therefore
how certain are you that this fully
functioning facility will be achieved by
March 26 at the latest so if you want to
come in Tony first and then K Rock
please I suppose to be honest not
terribly certain at all there are a lot
of things that will have to happen I I
think the DAT is of March 25 26 is what
we what we could do and that's based on
the the Gant chart of allowing a sort of
a reasonable period of time for each
stage that would be the soonest you
could deliver it if you started and
really pressed on
now for that to happen a lot of things
will have to happen in an expedient way
um the first thing that have to
happen there are two things that need to
happen in parallel actually which are
both first things you can't have two
firsts is we'll need to get the ICB to
sign up and agree to do it secondly
we'll need to get the bu Center design
um completed such that we know what site
we're putting this on know what shape of
building we can do because we can't
really progress the design until we know
where it's going and that consultation
is still ongoing at the moment so we
still haven't got an absolute fixed
start date the other things that will
influence it include the buildout rate
and the sort of housing market because
it's triggered by the contributions are
triggered by certain numbers of
completions on the site the completions
on the site are triggered by how many
sites sell and what the housing market
looks like so projecting forward we're
about the position we need to make a
start but there are quite a few unknowns
one of which is the the governance both
here and at the ICB making sort of
Speedy decisions to deliver it so um I
wouldn't sort of be booking your first
appointment for 20 six against the Crum
but we will that was an indication of
the sort of the earliest we could
deliver it yeah so I think we do need to
be realistic in what we are saying and
and not over promising or giving our
residents a false impression that this
is going to happen CC Ro I saw you nod a
couple of times and come in please yeah
thank you I think Council and
concerns are well placed the whole um
thing we're trying to do is to drive
forward the timing
as soon as we can by making an enabler
for a facility to be
provided uh to remove blockages that the
ICB May
perceive uh and and we bring this
facility there and I don't say put it on
a plate for them but it's there in front
of them uh and they can take their
decisions at the risk of repeating
myself I think it's worth saying the
procurement of The Operators the
Doctor's practice that's going to work
there is out with this this council's
control uh it's it's entirely up to them
we're we're making it as as feasible and
as expeditious as we can for them to do
it and uh that's been the concern
throughout so in terms of these dates if
everybody get gets on with it and does
it it's it's clearly feasible to do it
but as with all projects you don't know
what would happen and uh if there are
some delays uh Mr Perks and I have
discussed various ways of lubricating
the wheels that we could do uh and there
are triggers as he's mentioned within
the 106 to actually produce the money if
there a cash flow uh um in inhibition we
could look at that as and when that
arises but we're fully seized by the
need to get on with it as soon as we
possibly can um so I hope that's helpful
and I think you're quite right counselor
Crump that that is a big driver for us
what can word please thank you and
following on from that I mean yes the
biggest problem here I see with this
project the uncertainty of the project
not going at this earlier state is you
cannot calculate the
costs the costs are going up for
building materials quite horrendously at
the moment they will continue to do so
um uh what provision within the project
is there any provision with 106 to cope
with that additional uh uh cost which is
inevitably going to
happen um yeah the section 106 payments
we received have got an indexation on
them which I believe is CPI now so the
devil in the detail being how
construction prices perform relative to
CPI now that we're not um protected
against but there is an indexation sort
of measure on on the 106
contribution yep that far and the CPI I
understand it's just as good as the
purchasing managers index anywhere uh
which is not brilliant um so I mean what
provision should this District Council
be making to cover that
risk well the district council have an
obligation to Community Center size on
that site because we took that all we
signed the 106 agreement so if we are if
there's a shortfall on that side it'll
fall to the district council to find a
way of funding that and that would come
through a a borrow in contribution
Revenue contribution Capital
contribution we finding for reserves
depending on what it is we would be
liable for that because we've entered
that
commitment what we aren't liable for is
any sort of cost overruns on on the
health side relative to their proportion
to contribution nor the police for that
matter and the mechanism that we have in
the the the report there that we're
suggesting we would take forward into a
legal agreement if that's the way things
go is that um we would we would put the
capital into that we would borrow the
capital because the ICB have difficulty
in doing that and the iccb would pay us
a rent to cover the cost of servicing
that debt till the time that that that
debt was cleared so that that's the sort
of the mechanism in principle that we've
agreed to give us protection on the
health side but yeah the council when we
signed the 106 agreement took on the
risk of the RPI exceeding those building
cost exceeding RPI on the other side so
we'd have to S value engineer or borrow
for
that right any other
questions no I think we've raised our
concerns and I think counc Johnson is
raised his concerns as well got some
potential questions for for cabinet
on brilant thank you very much so the
next item
is again on the council uh on cabinet
papers the alternative fuel hvo for
Refuge
Vehicles which is
page 91 on the cabinet
papers now who would like
to start on this
one question yeah can Keith you raised
your questions earlier so would you like
to raise that question that
um sorry chair thanks very much um let
me just remind myself myself exactly how
I phrased that
question it was to do with the um hvo
and uh yeah do you want me to read it
for you I've got it now if you oh it's
okay you got it y yeah I'd rather read
it myself if that's okay with you no
problem
um yeah I mean um this this really is is
in respect of the
sustainability of this uh green diesel
biofuel
HV um
because um concerns are raised quite
widely that
um some of these oils are produced from
plantations that have uh given rise to
deforestation in some overseas countries
so the question is in light of the
proposed trial of HV in Refuge Vehicles
can the portf folio holder please
explain how we can ensure procurement of
fully traceable and certified hoo that
is from sustainable sources thank you
CH pfolio we don't actually have the
portfolio here do we we it's strictly
it's councel Junior ises climate change
so I think n is deing or I can answer
the question but I don't want to I'll
tell you what if if the r you want to
off then Nigel you come in and then Tony
if you want to fill in any gaps
afterwards thank you CH I'm I'm kind of
relaxed with whoever answers the
question as long as we get the right
answer I'll go first thank you thank you
counselor Keithley so biffer buys their
hydr cheated or hydrogenated vegetable
oil from sustainable sources and they're
provided with a z is it Zemo or zmo
certificate for the biffer purchases I
mean biffer already Supply hvo to other
fleets so this is not a new um thing for
them um so and they have they the zmo
certificate for the biffer purchases
demonstrate um this sustainability on a
quarterly
basis um any rtfo accredited as
suppliers which beffa uses will also
um um grut um initials and acronyms okay
um rtfo I can't
remember uh yeah there are accredited
suppliers and uh they must demonstrate
that they are using um C an accredited
amount of um so I've lost me place now
right so they they they can they can
beuse hvo fuel supply um is also
um um sorry I've lost me TR Tracer rable
transport fuel obligations oh thank you
yes under their retable transport fuel
obligations thank you everybody
okay oh yes I didn't read okay and um
basically they um work to remove all the
operational problems of supplying these
um this the fuel from non sort of um un
environmentally friendly sources and
these also comes under the The Institute
oh was the
IC um which um um certifies the fact
that the RO the um uh
uh ministri of Transport actually also
accredit the fact that these um um
suppliers which have an iscc certificate
are also supplying these from
environmentally friendly and sustainable
sources so anyway that's my bit go
thank you CC Ro you want to come in
please yeah but it's absolutely
important point that
um
there uh councelor Keith thank you very
much for pointing that out um has raised
that we don't want to end up in the
situation that somehow indirectly or
directly down the line We've Ended up in
deforestation for planting palm oil that
is something that is a a a clear uh
uh risk or effect we want to avoid and
we need to have that mechanism in place
to do that
um what I would say is comparing it with
what we do
now we don't know where diesel comes
from you know all sorts of things happen
in Nigeria for instance that uh may be
undesirable so I think we need to
contextualize that but uh you're
absolutely right councelor Keithley
because we're writing a new contract we
can put far more controls in it that
strangely enough we don't have at the
moment in terms of worldwide uh
transport impacts and uh and wider
environmental impacts so there actually
from that expect that expect we think we
can we can probably make an improvement
I hope
that's if I could
just if I could just say yeah thank you
for that explanation it's really
important that members understand there
is a certification process to ensure
that um HBO can come from sustainable
sources so that the um the uh well we
can be confident that it doesn't uh give
rise to uh deforestation and and
anti-environmental practices and also
extremely good point you just raised
councelor
rock thank you um in respect of the
sourcing of diesel because at the moment
we don't know where that comes from so
thank you thank you very
much Mr Perks you want to add anything
else no I think that my esteemed
colleagues have covered the issue very
well um which esteem
College uh cancel this one please oh
sorry councelor off no councelor Wally
hoggins I told you it was a good day
today councelor Wally
hoggins yes um so my understanding is
that there is a proposal to put up the
district council's um C council tax uh
segment by5 pounds brief calculations on
the back of a back of a notebook
suggests that four pounds of that5
pounds increase for every household will
actually go on this project um so my
question to you all is why do you think
given the fact that these are modern
upto-date
engines that are allowed to be used in
many inner city areas uh that you think
that this project
£250,000 per anom is a prudent use of
taxpayers money thank you in statford on
aen thank you very much indeed well
um I think it fair to say that any
environmental measure when it starts
off isn't free it isn't free at the
point of delivery what uh in the quality
man M terms would be called the exit
cost
equality you might not have noticed
Stratford just got flooded for the last
week um lots of bad things happen as a
result of climate change this Council
under the previous administration I have
to say but you unanimously voted uh for
a climate change
emergency measures to make the council
carbon neutral by
2030 there's no way we can make this
Council carbon neutral that doing
something about the carbon emissions
from The Refuge Fleet so we're going to
have to do something the question is
what uh at the moment this looks like
the only game in town however there is
there absolutely is a debate to have
just to put it in context back of an
envelope conf uh calculations as you
mentioned it's about Thro for every uh
bin
collection
uh
depends on your Viewpoint I mean throt
on a bin collection if that helps
climate
change at the moment to me seems Seems a
good deal but
um uh it's a debate to be had um and
I'll leave it at
that yeah follow on please
counc so the number of people that are
able to supply Supply the hvo from
sustainable sources is is very very
limited so how uh robust is the supply
chain that biffer uses for this because
once you've made the conversions and
dispensed with the diesel tanks then you
will have no alternative should Supply
run out other than to use the other
fuels thank you I I just it's just a
question really for biffer probably for
you to go back and ask that question but
that that you know there is no
competition in the market either it will
be a rising market market for all of you
thank
you sh shall I answer that one yes
please um Ju Just to say there is no
actual conversion of the trucks so it
isn't a if we go to this that's it
forever we can quite literally do it
next week and change our minds the week
after so we absolutely recognize that
yes you know things are changing the
more and more people that go on to want
in HBO kind of almost the you know one
sense that could either drive cost up or
make that sustainability you know harder
as more people go down that line um so
we absolutely know we haven't got those
absolute guarantees that there'll always
be an endless supply it is literally
something that we can do one week and
not the next if it becomes too expensive
if it doesn't give us the uh results
that we wanted we can stop it there is
no actual conversion of the trucks it's
purely a clean out of the actual tanks
so we can do it one week and not the
next we don't have to do it with all
trucks but that is something obviously
we will carefully monitor from the cost
to where we get it from everything going
forward question so you mentioned the
clean out of the tank so that is quite
right that the tanks do have to be
cleaned out in order to then take the
hvo so the therefore if the supply does
sort of fall flat you will then have a
delay there will be no bin collections
while those engines are cleaned out yes
again in order to take back the diesel
because that is the beauty of the Euro 6
engine it's it's why they've been it's
why they've been designed in
anticipation of this fuel coming down
the line the reason that every truck on
the road with the euro6 engine is not
using diesel my understanding is because
the cost of it is so prohibitive even
for all the big companies so my question
to you is then so how are you going to
manage then scenario because it's always
good to have that worst case scenario
planning that you've then got to clean
down the engines in order to take the
diesel again how are you going to sort
of mitigate or obviate uh the need for
the fact that uh Council bin collections
will be uh will be in Jeopardy for
certain residents thank
you yeah I think I think it comes down
to if there's one thing we're very very
good at it's operating and if there's
one thing I know is it's that we can
never ever have a delay to our Bing
collections we don't we have what while
the majority of our Fleet is our own
that we owned we also do quite often
have to either hire or lease vehicles in
obviously as we work through this
process with biffer we will make sure
that we have a full business continuity
plan in place so that we can cover every
single
scenario you know subject to there's a
fire at the Depot and you know we we
can't plan everything that's completely
unexpected but we will have a full plan
of you know contingency and business
continuity as to how we work this
through biffer do this already in some
other contracts and have already got a
lot of that covered but obviously we're
at the very early stages of talking
about you know what ifs and Mayes at
this point as we get a decision either
way if that's the way we're going we
will go into the the minutia operational
detail to make sure it is absolutely
deliverable um my question is then is
there nothing better that you can find
for the residents of Stratford District
Council to for the residents of
Stratford District to spend 2 million
ion pounds of their taxpayers money on
other than this project to put fuel into
already very clean vehicles thank you
and also the other question is you are
the libdems generally um do have um you
are renowned for consult consult
consultations with residents will you be
Consulting residents on your plans to to
do this thank
you uh
okay so right me up please well I think
the first emphasize this isn't a done
deal we're talking about it uh today
there will be a discussion at cabinet um
the recommendations if you read them uh
and they' be modified talks
about a um decision in
principle um it falls within the budget
the budget itself is is subject to
consultation that's going to come to
cabinet
um we're very keen as you say on on
hearing those
views uh and some of the points that are
come out today you know the there is
nothing black and white in in these
environmental measures and and we want
to hear those views and uh I brought my
book in 39 ways to save the planet
there's lots of different approaches in
in the world of environment and and Dave
passing and I have discussed this in in
other context
uh you know you just don't jump in
there's always pros and cons in doing
this so uh we are going to be in in
listening mode we we probably need more
information which we're only going to
get if we go down the line of exploring
the
contract uh and we're going to take on
board of the cabinet the views that are
expressed at this scrutiny
meeting um the finance portfolio is
making noises I'm not quite sure what
they are worried about spending his
money probably
but if he wants to come to the table and
say something I'm sure the chairman
would invite him to do
so Mr councel Curtis sorry I called you
Mr councel Cur if you want to come
forward if you just wa till
how thank you just an opportunity for a
factual correction
um Council W hoggins mentioned a figure
of2 million I believe just now it's not2
million it's 250 in the budget proposal
it's a cap of £250,000 per year for
three years so £750,000 rather than 2
million there is quite a significant
difference so thank you a definitive cap
of yes it is a definitive cap the um
section 151 officer Mr B and I have had
a number of conversations about the
affordability of this and based on those
conversations he has proposed that that
that is the figure that we should we we
are able to afford in the budget and as
Council Rock says this will go forward
for public consultation in full but I
just wanted to correct the actual figure
that Council Wally hoggins quoted then
thank you
chair Tony then and councelor W hoggins
and then I've got a couple of questions
as well okay I think it might be helpful
to the committee if I just sort of
outline some of the concerns I've heard
raised sort of partly within this
committee and partly out with about the
decision-making sort of process on this
so we're clear on it um the council have
an adopted policy relating to a climate
emergency that sort of sits on the books
and this initiative sort of responds to
that so that's your policy basis for
making the decision um the
council sorry the cabinet are
responsible for executive decisions of
the council and they're considering this
is an executive matter responding to the
the climate change motion but the budget
for doing this would be a decision
that's reserved for full Council so
there will be a decision you'll have
seen there's been a revised sort of
recommendation from this report
circulated to all counselors the cabinet
will be asked to consider the report on
Monday subject to the budget that are
being available through the of the
budget process that will be subject to
sort of a public consultation exercise
and that will be reported back to sort
of fall Council for a decision so the
the budget for this is a matter reserve
for full Council the spending of the
money is reserved for full Council and
that will be subject to public
consultation the cabinet are making an
executive recommendation on Monday um
relying on the the policy that was
passed when the council de declared a
climate emergency going back a couple of
years so I just thought it might be
useful to in context to that CU I know
there there has been
some some suggestions that it's improper
for the cabinet to make this decision
decision but the the financing of it is
reserved for ccel that be going through
D
process counc
hogin yeah I might need you to come back
counselor Curtis actually so um
apologies for getting that yes 250,000
per ano I acknowledge that what is going
to happen if um the as predictions that
I've seen are that the cost for hvo
increases rather than it decreases what
are you going to do then if those costs
look like they're spiraling out of
control what is this Council going to do
then thank
you will the what I'm trying to say is
as part of the budget and will you say
no you can't do this cancel Rock has
indicated whe whether to answer that say
bringing Council Curtis
back um I think Julie covered that in
that they we've um oh G have to focus oh
you're right now you got your focus back
now that probably tells you something
but um uh I think as uh as the head of
service said one of one of the
advantages of this is its ability to be
fully uh
reversible you said we could reverse it
next week and you at today's notice I
obviously there's there's a a project
management involved in doing that so
clearly um officers are going to be
keeping an eye on this I'm sure biffer
will be depending upon what in the in
the terms of the
contract this is the one major advantage
obviously as I said there's a debate to
be had about all these points within it
but one major Plus on it is no no
modifications of the vehicle which in
fact Sarah W hoggins councelor W hoggins
has mentioned so if it it looks
difficult and of course it could go
either way is we can we can readily
revise it if we had to do some major
Capital Investments to um
to modify vehicles that that would be a
disadvantage but we are in that position
we can respond to Market forces in that
way cancel little then I'll bring you
back in thank you chair um so could you
turn your microphone off please yeah I I
I I I I fully support the idea of um
sustainability and looking forward and
climate control Etc I don't think
anybody argues about that I don't think
there are many people who don't believe
that climate change is happening anymore
um and and we've already talked about
the the cost and penalties and risks of
early adoption you pay those those a
risk to normally take a commercial gain
um that doesn't apply in this case
obviously it's the planet we're talking
about but one question that keeps on
nagging at me is why and how is this
project this uh for for uh hvos any
different from the pro the project and
the program that was run in Germany in
the early ughs which lasted about four
or five years and then was cancelled by
the federal government because of
unsustainability well you have the
advantage of me because I don't know
what program you're talking about
so
um well I can't answer the question
because you'll perhaps explain it more
and we'll have a go
well it's matter of record in Germany of
course but uh um yes there was
unsustainability um there was a
combination of um U uled rape uh
products uh combination of re majority
of recycled oil the project failed
because it was impossible to recycle
sufficient oil from uh um um collection
the costs were prohibitive um and the
use of land uh which was being diverted
from food production became unacceptable
it's as simple as that
really I I am concerned that this is a
technology which is a knee-jerk and I
would really caution um Council caution
on on this project and I think you've
already indicated that this is
discussion
Point uh yeah well first of all um I'm
personally not in favor of growing crops
for
energy uh as a first
choice and uh um again I've got I've got
the book here I was talking to Tom Heap
about this uh if if you grow energy
crops compared with for instance putting
solar on it's about 30 times the ratio
it's not an efficient way of of
capturing solar for energy through crops
it's not it's not a good idea unless is
some other way of doing it on the other
hand we're proposing to use waste this
is to use waste that would otherwise go
for animal an feed now I'm not an expert
on this you need counselor junid so I'm
standing in she's the expert on this but
if you give it to animal feed you give
it to animals it turns into methane
methane's about 60 times the carbon uh
the um uh climate damage of of carbon so
we're not growing rape or palm oil to go
into into this fuel so that's that's the
thing we are say aiming prohibiting
avoiding whatever want to we want to use
so I think those uh those concerns are
well founded and we are trying to do our
best to avoid and we'll withraw to avoid
in the contract negotiations but we do
have to carry this forward as a matter
of principle to investigate it and to
shut down all those difficulties and
risks that you
identify thank you and and and I agree
with what you've just said but I go back
to the previous uh my previous statement
about the project in in in in Germany
and I really do think it should be
investigated and Lessons Learned the
reason that it was failed it failed was
because there was insufficient supply of
the of of recycled oil and um um the the
fact of the matter is as an early
adopter you may be able to get away with
that and there may be sufficient but if
the whole world changes over to it you
haven't got hope and the cost will be
prohibitive and I don't think that at
this stage this project has been looked
through technically and historically
sufficiently I mean that is a
fundamental flaw with the argument and
I'm sure the producers of hoo will have
convinced us all just like petroleum and
and and the and the tobacco companies
about the safety of cigarettes they have
a commercial interest in doing so we
have an a duty to our
um the population who pay the their tax
to look into this and take good care
nobody wants to have to say sorry after
the
event I've I'll come in now and then
I'll bring in Kel p and canel Huggins
then I think we'll we'll draw to a close
um I've got a couple the points um
firstly how robust is the the cost and
behind this and in the inflation it
might have been sensible whether there's
some blue papers could have been
attached to this report to give some
breakdown for members to see what was
happening about this I don't think that
would be
unreasonable um secondly
the if we do the climate change Reserve
which is 1.2 million and if we're going
to use
750,000 that's 62 a half% 58 of that uh
so that's a significant amount if we'
going to do that so leaving that climate
change fund either less money in or it
would need topping up for for future
usage um so there's a couple things that
and also what happened to option four on
on
on on my one you know was option four
that unacceptable it was taken out so
obviously with my Finance gek on if we
can't get the number in right when we're
looking at £250,000 worth of income
expenditure it would be good if we'd got
all the numbers we might have the right
numbers but not necessarily in the right
place um so yeah just some thoughts and
comments on that
please I'll pick that up if you like um
in terms of the robust
costing oh the other thing sorry another
thing I forgot to say is the experience
sorry Tony I'll started s this um I
apologize for that um the head of
service said that
other Refuge providers were were further
down the route on this um so what are
our experiences how of how robust is
their supply what is the cost H have
there been any teething problems
associated with it
so just that was probably most
pertinent in terms of the costing that
there is a volatility in the fuel Market
because it sort of it relates back to
the price of diesel generally doesn't it
and so there is volatility there is at
the moment a premium for buying hvo for
the cost of diesel and that's what's
reflected sort of in the bid you have
ahead of you I think we've sort of
discussed I can't give I don't think any
of us here can give you cost certainty
on where the HBO or the diesel price is
going in the medium term um but we have
sort of given measures that we can
mitigate back to being no more at risk
than we were before by reverting to
diesel should we choose to do so and if
that situation came we would come back
to the decision-making bodies to decide
what you wanted to do but you you have
an option there that doesn't place you
at any additional risk Beyond where you
are today if you choose to take it um in
terms of the climate change Reserve that
is an option in the report
um I don't think think that that is a
preferred option because within the sort
of the budget consultation we put out to
public consultation there is a figure to
allow for this to be sort of put in in
addition to that if it failed at the
budget consultation because the council
didn't back it the C the cabinet I
suppose would have to take a view about
whether they thought that was more
appropriate funded from the climate
change Reserve but that's a sort of I
wouldn't like to speculate on that
decision that' be a political matter for
the cabinet should that situation apply
so hope that give you some comfort on
that but it's not planned to drain the
cab the CL CL change Reserve to sort of
fund this initiative at the moment um I
apologize for the lack of an option for
I think somebody was very good counting
um and the feedback we've had from the
biffer partners that are using hvo has
has been positive biffer came to us
advocating this as a way of working that
would sort of me we put to
biffer the challenge that we were facing
with the climate change emergency that
was declared and our Target to become
zero carbon and we said what can we do
with the trucks and we have had a sort
of a couple of quite extensive workshops
looking at electrification hydrogen sort
of alternative methane fuels and what
was near to Market what was achievable
what the budgets were against each which
are they used in practice and in a rural
District like ours their firm
recommendation based on their experience
of operating sort of both sort of
municipal waste trucks and other
vehicles around the country on
Commercial basis was that hvo was was
the best option for us probably as an
interim solution to hopefully move into
a hydrogen or stroke electric solution
sort of one those Technologies developed
but with the geography of our district
and the location of our disposal points
in centry and electric or hydrogen
solution isn't practical for us at the
moment so to address your climate change
initiatives you're really faced with
either sort of hvo or some sort of
offsetting or acknowledging that the
target is unrealistic which um would be
a political consequence so that That's
the basis of the report we presented
today ccor Rock do you want to come in
and answer that yes just just on that
point about other authorities
um I mean Julie may may know more but it
looks to me there are at least 20 other
authorities that have gone down this
line and there are about 20 other
commercial
businesses I'm I'm sure lots of people
like me go and visit Screwfix there
delivery Fleet is uh uh fueled by uh
hvo um I have spoken uh to uh the
nearest off Authority that uses it which
is hlin Bosworth District Council they
very similar Council to ourselves in
terms of their area I mean nobody's got
such a big area of as us actually there
are but I mean you know 979 square
kilometers uh but they're very similar
to us they've got a large rural area
with a a couple of one big town and
Market areas and they're very happy with
the transition they've made um I think
possibly in the course of doing this
work listening to what's been said I
think uh doing a bit more work to to
listen to the experience of that uh as
we go through uh the um implementation
investigation May well be uh something
we might do but it seems to be positive
feedback from everybody that's doing it
noting of course the early doctor
comments that been made by Council
wood so I again I think that I think the
basis of the report is fine um currently
obviously I would have liked to send
more cost in than that could have been
in the in the price in the blue papers
and secondly that context about the
other users uh the Hinkley and Bosworth
Etc would have been quite relevant for
the discussion part of the paper so I'm
disappointed that's not in because we
could have stopped some of the questions
that we've just asked already it
wouldn't made sense to say well so many
people are using it already their
initial experiences are this and we feel
we could get the benefits similar to
those um and and that doesn't seem to be
here the report we just come the way I'm
read it I might be reading it totally
wrongly is that coming we you we're one
of the first ones here and we we're
going to be taking a lot of the risk
where some people are already down that
route so they experiences so I think
that would have
been helpful or beneficial in in the
report so if that could be noted as well
please right I've had my run now um Can
the passinger I'll bring you in then
I've got canc the Wally hoggins then
canel R will Clos inion for
us
um yeah in general and taking over a
number of
years uh saving uh reducing carbon
emissions will save money because you're
wasting less energy and less um fuel on
on on uh heating things and so on and
and transport so the the um the uh refu
lorries consume or or emit about a third
of the
council's uh carbon emissions uh so are
there um savings that can be shown
already or in the future on the other
two reducing the other 2third that will
in effect help pay for this this
possible increase in cost if the current
uh pricing stays the same and and and
diesel prices don't go up as well or
whatever which we don't know it's all
bit uncertain so are are there other
savings that can made that will save
costs as
well uh well as we said in an earlier
part of the discussion we're working our
way through for instance the estate as
as to what we can do
uh as members may I know I used to I
used to work for a low carbon
consultancy and our experience there is
uh if you put low carbon measures in you
invest to save you have to put some
money in UPF front and capital but over
over time you get your money back and
certainly the solar panels in my house
have done that um so we are working
through that program in all areas of the
council and we will be doing that uh and
indeed there as it pointed out there are
other lines in the budget to achieve
that um what the details of that are
require investigation and nobody wants
to take decisions in haste as we've just
been discussing here we want to work
through those things and take rational
decisions on in time after appropriate
investigation on the other hand we've
got a climate emergency which is a
decision we took in 2019 so there's a
balance to be struck there but it is my
opinion that uh the more we get into
energy saving it not only benefits the
planet but over time it will save us
Revenue
costs counc W hoggins
please uh yeah it's a question but also
a hope that perhaps perhaps this could
happen really you know is what
monitoring of hvo costs and availability
has leadership of this Council done
before proposing this and why not do
that now for a period of time and then
wait pause before you do this so that
we've fully armed with the facts rather
than this being a knee-jerk reaction
because this is an easy win for this
Council uh leadership to say with
regards to the to the next Net Zero it
does need far more careful monitoring
before this decision is made because
also moving back to Diesel from hvo um
you
know and I say this kindly you know it
doesn't look good for anybody does it it
will be a failed initiative almost thank
you can the rice next then C the RO
please yes um I'm just interested in the
remarks that Mr Mr Perks made about this
being an interim measure it's in the
budget capped at uh 250,000 for 3 years
I was just wondering in the discussions
that you've had with biffer uh was there
any indication of um when um fuel cells
or battery powered vehicles would be um
an a realistic affordable
alternative um I don't think there are
any sort of dates that we could place
any sort of great Reliance on this
technolog is always 5 years away they
tell us um we looked at it long and hard
um when we procured the last Fleet of
trucks we tend to buy our we don't buy
all our trucks in one time but the
renewal of contracts and extension of
contract we tend to replace trucks and
then they're supplemented by trucks for
grow population growth along the way so
the bulk of the trucks are bought as one
purchased we looked very long and harded
it then and there wasn't a technology at
that time that would um suit our needs
um we tend to run trucks over around
about 8e cycle which coincides with the
length before the waste contract is due
for either renewal or reter so there
will be another opportunity to look long
and hard at it then um and in the
interim if the technology comes along as
we buy trucks to support population
growth it might be possible to trial a a
truck as part of that process we're very
alive to those opportunities and of the
the current Administration sort of
keeping my feet to the fire to make sure
I don't miss any of those um but at the
moment I can't offer you a definite date
when we could run either a hydrogen or
an electric vehicle or a sort of
biomethane vehicle effectively to cope
with the rural area that we've got on
the Tipping conditions that we have but
I I should keep you a breast of any
changes Council R
please um as much as um all this
discussion about cost is important um
nobody's mentioned the most important
thing about doing this which is is the
health of our residents by reducing all
these emissions in our towns and rural
areas um this is this is going to
benefit our residents um and I don't
think we should just solely hone in on
finance this is the health of our kids
of us of our future let's just get that
into
perspective Council
kiy uh thanks chair and thank you
councelor Rolf for that um intervention
I think if uh any of our residents are
listening in they would be greatly
concerned to hear proposals that we
should prevaricate hold off
monitor not go ahead with this when
we've had a climate emergency declared
for four years and there are new
numerous other local authorities that
have already moved to this
fuel um to benefit the climate and to
benefit residents and children and
grandchildren so um I'm very much in
favor of moving on this very quickly and
not
prevaricating thank you um go on then k
sorry only a quick one Council rol stole
my thunder because I am concerned in
where I live the amount of trucks that
come through and the the monitoring of
uh the pollution is way above what it
should be and if any um thing can
improve this as can R has said the
health of the residents that's important
we should move forward and look at these
sort of things constructively okay thank
you yeah just just a some just go back
to cancer Keith's point I think is the
scrutiny committee with we've got a duty
to make sure we're using our resources
wisely and efficiently and most
effective way what I think would have
been helpful and we wouldn't have been
pre saying about
prevaricating is if we'd had the
information that other um that Council
Rock said like hinley and Bosworth were
using and were further down the road and
therefore we weren't going to be the
first there we were going to be further
down the route listening and learning
from other people's experiences
and I think that was probably a flaw in
the report again I've got my points
about the costing I think that was done
as well so I think the report in my
opinion might again I might be the only
one I think the report was
rushed or needed improving before I can
understand why it needed to come
urgently but more time should have been
spent on getting the detail that would
abled us to scrutinize this properly
therefore we W to set hairs running
saying well this is untried technology
it's already been used in hinley and
Bosworth and the effects of this this
and this um they've taken this into
account uh biffer are using this already
in so and so so I think that would have
definitely been helpful and probably
shorten the the debate and I think we've
got a right to do this is scrutiny
committee um and you know that's why you
know I think as chair I think we need to
be doing this um I agree with the
principles but again I'm concern is like
say councelor Curtis said a threeyear
capped figure of £250,000 and I read the
read the report that if we it doesn't
work we can revert back to diesel so
again that sets the question are we
going early are we doing this premature
so therefore you know we set ourselves
up to fail but that question again would
have been answered if we' have got the
details about the other things so I
think
we've got a fair points here you know I
would stand by the comment that we've
got to challenge them um but we do need
the information if we're going to
scrutinize we need all the information
we're going back to the the point here
we're on about markets um and we will
talk about that and we will get the
information um towards the end of the
year where we we can then scrutinize see
what's been done but we can't scrutinize
if we haven't got the information is my
bottom line so that's my uh
uh protic point there um so hopefully
I've sum that up again I'll be looking
forward to the debate at the cabinet on
Monday um and hopefully V the um Deputy
leader and portfolio holders there there
will take that into account C you can
have the final word please yes I just
wanted to say I wanted to thank the
committee for all the points have made
because um as we said at the beginning
we are listening to what's been said um
and uh Council Judy is not here so I
apologize for of my lesser knowledge
about the environment than her but um I
think a lot of it's been very good
discussion I think it's been very
interesting a lot of interesting points
to be made uh as far as I'm concerned I
I'll try and make sure those points are
are considered when we discuss this at
the cabinet and uh I do thank you for
everybody for your contributions thank
you chairman very thank you right then
we'll move on to item number eight
something that people have got a lot of
interest in public
houses um why does everybody sudden you
start smiling there uh we've got we'll
we'll do a couple of things here like I
said earlier we'll talk about the task
and finish group on the public houses
and we'll talk about the task unfinish
group on the budget which counts the
Johnson will lead on um but uh who um
who wants to kick off on oh we've got Mr
careford
yeah right I'll I'll let Howard um kick
off first and then John if you want to
come in just
briefly then you give the details yeah
uh thanks chair yeah just briefly um so
this began as a notice motion to council
um was referred to cabinet and Mr
careford prepared a report for cabinet
um advising on sort of the planning
policies it stands and possible uh
options that the council could take to
further protect um and preserve public
houses in the
district um so going from that
recommendation um you've got before you
a scoping document proposing sort of the
scope of the task and finish group um a
draft terms of reference and some
initial findings uh regarding public
houses and closures in the last four
years and we're also looking to uh if
possible uh determine the membership of
the group so we can kick things off
today as well we're looking for roughly
three to five
members who uh can johnon come on this
one you want to come on the other one
I've interested in joining this group
got a little bit of task and finish
group congestion at the moment that
hopefully it'll clarify itself I'm
afraid there won't be any site V visits
on this
one I'm sure we'll be able to organize
that one way or another can a little one
please thank you chair yeah well you
can't have everything can you um I i'
I'd be interested in I I I support uh
the the the principles behind this this
work and uh I'd be interested in join
the group um but as a matter of
background
I I I really can't believe that I did it
but uh once in my career I did actually
I was actually a lener so I have an
inside knowledge and understanding of
the industry I think which might be
constructive and helpful was that when
you were in Germany you were known as
mine
host it wasn't in Germany but it was in
a mining
area very good um cancor Wally hoggins
please yeah the reason this document is
before you today is because it was a
proposal that I put forward my name is
written on it because I was away on
holiday when this came to full Council R
and debate and it was all the back of
the fact that so many pubs in my
particular Ward have already closed um
including the gate in at uh in brails
and now we're fac it's ongoing is the
foxman house at Great wford which have
just been notified uh is once again
coming through uh is going to be coming
to planing committee reasonably quickly
again uh and this really matters to me
it's at the heart of my reward and
therefore I would really like to be part
of the uh task and finish group for for
this mainly because as I said much of
what was written here um I I actually
wrote and proposed thank you very much
indeed councelor or
please machine please
thank you is it working yes um yes I'd
like to join this task and finish group
as well uh please I in my role of
knowing a lot of a lot of and that
sounded Dreadful didn't it um I have a
lot of my friends who are either
managers of
pubs um or you know lenses of different
pubs and have taken on different pubs to
try and help them through uh the more
difficult times and I think my knowledge
would would be quite beneficial and
chairperson of the council you have to
go to various licensed premises don't
you so therefore of so that that was
your main reason for putting yourself
forward absolutely why I knew you wanted
to say that but you couldn't quite come
up thank you right um got for anybody
else interested or we start before and
then
again again if you want to cut people on
to bring them again I'm concerned about
it becoming unwieldy if we happy that uh
Mr careford any comments so you Happ
with this any thoughts what we could go
on
this uh Happy New Year members um no it
was really just to uh listen in and uh
you be here should any questions rise
but uh no I think that's a a good number
uh good selection and I I think yeah if
we can just work out a detailed
timetable uh about how we progress this
one um and the the frequency of those
meetings I think that' be useful thank
you
brilliant ccor
Keely thank you chair um I'm not
proposing to join the group I don't have
that much experience of drinking in
pubs maybe if I join the group I'd have
more experience of drinking in pubs I'm
just interested to know this isn't just
a problem in strapford District is it
I'm just interested to know is is there
anything else out there that other
authorities are doing at the same time
maybe Council W comment on that yeah
there is a document become much more
robust about this um documents that I've
you know I have that I have shared that
and I'm happy to share that with the
whole of the overview scrutiny committee
it's it's it's a there is much on that
document I'm sure you're familiar with
it too uh J I did share that with you as
well um it's a very useful document um
it makes it makes the difficult reading
actually but it's also the document is
also a warning to those that seek to buy
pubs as a development opportunity as
well so if I if I share that with you
you know but also you know once those
things have been done robustly you know
it it really focuses the mind on on what
should be going on in straford thank you
I'll bring Mr ke and then cast
off yeah I think to to answer that point
I think the group will certainly look at
um what's happening
elsewhere uh you know what's going on
best practice and um possibly whether we
can bring bring in um you know people
like camera campaign for real hour to
see what their experiences I know
they've uh they've raised concerns about
puup closures so I think I think that
this is the whole point of the group to
say okay what what is it we can do about
it to address address the concern really
and yeah I think we can we can certainly
look at things on that great thank you C
please um I don't want to join the group
because um I I don't uh
drink anyway um uh what I want to ask is
um there is such a thing as uh as uh
things like pubs becoming Community
assets could are you able to explain
John the kind of status of community
assets I mean I think I know but maybe
not everybody does
know I wonder if Mr Perks might be
better placed he deals with it at the
council happy your advise if that would
be useful um it is possible to WR in
certain CC cumstances it is possible to
register sort of pubs as assets of
community value there are a number of
tests that they have to satisfy they
have to be S of actually providing
Community benefit or have the potential
to provide it in sort of a realistic
time scale which is usually sort of five
years um and to have Community benefit
you would normally it would normally be
like the last Pub in ability if there
are 20 pubs all in a line it's a job to
argue that they're all providing
Community benefit but if you were down
to the last sort of one or two then it
is possible to list it as an asset of
community value that gives you sort of
two levels of protection to the
asset if somebody chooses to sell the
pub then if a community group can get a
there are there's a moratorium period
where a community groups can get
together to put together a bid to buy
the asset the seller of the pub isn't
bound to accept the offer that comes
from that group they can't sell the pub
until the group have got together and
made their best offer so it's a a sort
of protection there the other protection
offers is it is a material consideration
in the planning process so if somebody
were to um apply to change the use of a
pub um if it were registered as an asset
of community value that would be
material consideration that isn't to say
that it can never get planning
permission but it's something that has
to be explored as part of the planning
process so those are the two levels of
protection you get through the sity
process canc rise
please um yeah just a couple of uh well
a point actually to start with I'm
surprised it says here in appendix 3
that there have been uh 12 closures
since
2019 I think that doesn't sound like a
hard enough number I mean I'm aware of
three within a couple of miles of where
I live and Stratford district is much
much bigger so I would be surprised if
it's only 12 I I'm not sure where the
DAT has come from but the point I really
wanted to make was um the scope of the
task and finish group uh do we really
need to consider the significance of the
loss of public houses I mean surely
that's taken as R by the very fact we're
having a task and finish
group I suppose just in answer to that
it it depends how how many other pubs
there are in I suppose it needed to be a
bit more nuanced how if it was the only
Pub left in the settlement Village Etc
it would be whereas if there were seven
the right in that vage there would be
less significant so I
think it could be more nuanced about
that but I can understand your point but
I think it's you know it's something we
need to need to explore can W hoggins
yeah can I ask um Mr careford then um
what is this is a really significant
piece of work that's going on here and
what is going to happen with all those
applications that the council currently
has for change of use for public houses
in light of this um this task and finish
group being set up because there has
been quite some considerable day delay I
would suggest since this was first
proposed back in July and agreed to to
the point in time where we're at now in
January what I'm seeking to do is that
this this really the bottom line this
task and group is my suggestion is that
it is not at a landlord's behal to just
shut the door and declare it unviable
and never to reopen it that is the whole
fundamental point point of this but you
know what is you know there are planning
applications in at the moment being
considered what are you going to do in
order to make sure that they are fairly
dealt with on the back of the fact that
this task and finish group has been
known to be being set up for some
considerable time now thank
you I I think it' be unreasonable
to use the existence of the task finish
group to influence the applications
currently but obviously depending on the
outcome of the uh task and finish group
uh it may be that some of the
information gleaned and the new approach
can become a material consideration so I
I don't think at the current time it it
changes
anything this is really significant and
I do actually need some clar it on this
because it is important because I think
there are material considerations that
are going to make a big difference to
the residents and communities of
Stratford on aen one particular
Community you know exactly which one it
is as well and I I am a gast a at the
decisions that are currently being made
but that the fact that this piece of
work that should have been up and
running much sooner um is going to
potentially be um have a devastating
effect on the outcome of a of a
forthcoming and the date has not yet
been been agreed for that and I do think
that as a council we need to be very
careful with given the gravity of the
situation and those involved and the
appeal process as well thank you can can
you come back to me with or can we have
a discussion offline about this please
but I am taking this very seriously
thank
you thank you I think that's it's a
really good debate we've got four for uh
winning volunteers um for for various
different reasons um so I think uh we're
happy with those so cancel little
councelor Johnson uh cancel W hoggins
and councelor orup for the four um I
think the terms of reference are
reasonable if we're happy to agree those
but again if the working group wants to
come back with some slight tweak into
the terms of reference we could do that
at the next meeting I'm I'm happy with
that um so can I uh agree that for the
the public houses at the task and finish
group so we're all happy with that um we
were going to add on now the budget task
and finish Group which is chaired by
canel Johnson and vice chairman canel
pasum and I will pass over to canel
Johnson to come in on that please thank
you for that we met last Wednesday and
we'll be meeting in the next two
Wednesdays um um we look particularly uh
Richard borl led us through the process
of looking particularly at the
medium-term financial strategy we
queried some of the third fourth and
fifth year reasoning but we were
satisfied with Mr Burl's um
reasoning we drew attention to the fact
that um inflation is back with us and
that reserves that were worth you know
10 million this year will not be worth
10 million in 5 years time um there
were three things that it might be
useful chair for you to raise um at the
cabinet one we felt that the council
plan and change
program needed more clarity so we could
understand what that included and we
felt cabinet could do some more work on
on that
um we wanted to be confident that the HR
budget included sufficient resources to
implement the staff strategy which the
council agreed last
December and there was a discussion
about where the um where we now sat on
biodiversity net
gain and how that was incorporated into
the budget and where the costs would be
carried
um we' obviously got another two
meetings I'm Keen that we um look at
fees and charges particularly against
performance um and uh I'm sure other
members of the group will come forward
with other suggestions but I do think
it'd be useful if we could give Mr Burl
a bit of warning before Wednesday of
things that we
uh we wanted him to deal
with brilant thank you for that uh
before we go on I don't know whether
there's any other questions or points of
clarifications we've got two minutes
before we have to vote uh on carrying on
past the three hours um so any other
questions on that are we are we happy
that I take this forward to cabinet and
agree note the progress of the task
groupt thank you for that uh and the
next one is the work plan obviously
we've said how busy we are in February
we need to make make sure we are there
uh and focus and be available one thing
I did mention that I'd like in the in
the future perhaps September October is
an update on the markets regarding the
traffic management and all the um
lessons learned I think that was found
reasonable um but I think again we'll
we'll play by here next month we are
really going to be busy so I think I
think we're
the carry on as we are so we're happy we
that one and no urgent business the any
urgent business is again just to
reemphasize that the 9th of February
meeting we're going to be a long one so
make sure you're well prepared for that
so no other questions answers I think
we've just about finished within the
three
hours thank
you